Hello everybody!
Welcome back to Sandlam!
I think it's been like what, two weeks since we played part
two?
This is the worst thing I can do in my channel.
Okay, here's a pro tip for you guys.
Playing, doing a part three of a series two weeks later of a
long, of a sort of RPG game is not the smartest thing you
should do.
she was enjoying Sandland so but I don't care because
Sandland has been very enjoyable and like even though it's
been through two weeks since we played part two and a lot of
you might have already forgotten what the fuck happened it's
okay we're starting a new story because apparently um in
part two we finished the original story of sandland and we
were just about to start a new story where we're not in the
sand anymore uh so there's that also because like banda has
been treating me really well like the uh banda america and i
guess like jp as well um they've been treating me really
well and like you know what like i honestly i've been
enjoying sandland i was Like, I'm going to keep going.
I'm going to keep going.
Keep advertising Sandland for those who forgot about it.
Because I enjoy the game.
And I enjoy Bandai.
But yes.
Let's go.
Alright, Sandland.
Guys, like I said, you actually don't have to know about
what happened last time.
Because we're starting a whole new fucking story.
Thank you for the gifted ship, Deadpool.
you i really appreciate it oh no why is my controller not
working no did it register my fucking mouse okay i hope i
don't get uh marked for demonetization for saying the f word
all right guys i need to reboot the game because i have to i
had to boot it up while i was on a controller give me a sec
give me a sec all right we're starting a new season a new
season of sand where it's green now uh also like uh just
want to guys that you know next week will be quote unquote
wet rest week other than like i think i have like that
twitch rivals thing wait it's actually not registering
excuse you excuse me hello okay maybe if i if i click
continue it'll register hello sir okay maybe if i like press
escape and go to oh all right let's go control setup there
you go yes control type yes yes control type oh all right my
i'm sorry okay i have an idea i have an idea idea on how to
fix this okay uh controller settings yes yes okay does that
mean it's gonna configure it now does that it says
controllers activate it how did i how did i do this
was i playing a controller last time oh i did it i had to
re-plug it oh my gosh i knew it when all else fails just
plug it it turn it on and off again all right oh hey there
was a monkey guys i don't remember how i play this game uh
what was the object oh i have to talk oh i have to talk to
the talk to people yes there we go oh my gosh tangent here
okay i need a moderate tangent a tangent oh tangent's a
member oh my god all right nice you're just a standard
moderator You don't have that much power on my channel Oh my
Tengen, you fake ass fan You said you were always a member
What the fuck happened?
Your tomato, that's like the first membership If you were
always a member You would have been an egg right now Thank
you for joining the tomato farm Tengen I hope you had a
great debut I was sleeping so I couldn't retweet it in time
I was tired.
Is that what he thinks?
Let's bring the more supplies later and see if they can fix
my console.
Sounds like a plan.
Oh my god.
Congratulations on your debut, Tengen.
You should grow.
You know what?
But you didn't gorilla streamed it.
You said the moment is everything's ready, you would make a
waiting room and turn your stream on.
You already lied to me.
Master drop, thank you for the 50 gift and chips.
Thank you, thank you.
Us too?
What do you mean?
We've lost contact with the unit tasked to guard the
battleship.
And when we dispatched another nearby unit to investigate,
there went AWOL 2.
Fake and real friend.
So now you want the old man to look into it for you?
Wait, someone stole our ships?
No!
You never know where I might show up.
The taxpayer's money!
The battleship belonged to Zayu.
But I check out Tenjin.
He just recently debuted, guys.
He has a new skin suit now.
Something about his chin.
I saw...
Tenjin, why was everybody talking about your chin?
I didn't watch your debut yet.
I'm confused.
Would you like to explain if you're still here?
Tension?
Or why are people calling you tension?
Well, you heard the brief.
Are you two coming along?
Sure.
Sounds fun.
Thanks.
I just hope we don't run into anything too crazy.
Have a mountain of a chance.
What is it?
Going up, but like, that game?
But on Tension's chin.
Zayu's battleship crash landed somewhere around the big dam.
They're there for the peachy.
Yes.
How do I...
The royal army.
Okay, oh, there we go.
Alright, I need to grab the tank.
Because it's fast.
Wait, no.
I need to get a motorcycle because it's faster.
The others can walk.
We don't know.
Maybe they're Transmitters just malfunctioned.
Well, I certainly hope so.
Alright, off I go.
It's alright, I don't really care about the others.
They can just walk.
Wait, do I fast travel?
Where is it?
Oh, no.
It's too far.
The fast travel is not...
Wait, unless?
Is this...
No!
I don't have the fast travel for this.
Guys, I fast...
out so apparently by the way guys apparently what the fuck
there's a crocodile now in this game okay I was so busy
looking at the crocodile almost fell off okay um what was I
gonna say oh yeah apparently if I had done the side quest I
could have decorated my base and everything and also put
stickers and change the colors of my tanks.
So, like, oops.
Alright, well, oopsie.
Apparently, you know, I didn't, I didn't unlock any of the
actual fun parts of this, like, the actual fun parts of
customization of this game, just because I've been ignoring
all these.
So, I'm like, what?
You live in a look.
oopsie so you know that 50 chairs i got the 50 chairs i got
from the uh from pre-ordering yeah i'm still own 50 chairs
i think chad told you several times look i chose to not see
okay
It's not my fault that, like, you know, I didn't see it when
I chose to not see, guys.
You guys should have yelled at me harder, so it was harder
for me to choose to not see.
Let's see, we're almost there.
Yeah, we're almost here.
No, it's not my fault.
You just didn't yell hard enough at me.
If you yell hard enough at me, then I couldn't choose to not
see, because I'll be like, saying that so how can I choose
to to ignore it if like it's harder to ignore you got you
get me you understand oh yeah you're so sure but with large
groups you risk getting surrounded all right let's see where
I go is this where we go to Greenland oh my god this guy's
dead oh no he's dead I wish you could have ran him over that
now you're hearing this that would have been so bad I
actually don't hear this bad that I please don't take my
advice okay what the heck just happened some group I've
never seen before suddenly attack yeah thank you the super
chat Hello chat is I a dragoon who has plazzed this game.
Doki's town has no features because she's skipped every side
quest.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Not on purpose.
It was not willingly skipped.
Okay.
They just didn't put it in my face hard enough.
More like passed out.
Who could defeat elite royal army soldiers in an instant?
Yeah, who could do that?
Wait, can I still unlock it?
Or did I like leave my home already?
guys, it doesn't mean it guys, it doesn't mean that I can't
unlock it alright, okay guys, you know what fuck you guys,
okay I'm gonna do this out of spite now we're not going to
Greenland anymore
we could have been in Greenland already but we're not going
to Greenland anymore we're gonna we're gonna features we're
Where is our home?
We demand green.
Guys, I'm having trouble finding green like our home.
Oh, it's here.
That should be it.
Why can't I fucking fast travel?
Fast travel to this.
Oh, I have to like zoom in, I guess.
It has to be this.
Yeah.
No?
Wait, this is not my home.
Guys, give me a sec.
I'm trying to remember where we used to live.
This is... No, this is the nest.
Guys, where did we live?
That's the ruins.
That's the...
Is Spino?
Guys, I don't even know where we lived, guys.
That's nap space.
Talbo.
Nest.
Water supply.
Where's my house?
Oh, Spino!
There he is.
Are you gonna pick up Fallout 4 again?
Young, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm gonna see after Sandland.
We'll see.
But thank you for the super chat, Young.
Thank you, thank you.
Sad Kermit, thank you for 20.
Get the ships.
Thank you, thank you.
Okay, what was the first side quest, guys?
Come on.
There's not even any side quest.
Here.
There's nobody offering side quest.
Golden help.
for the super chat thank you thank you stop complaining i
swear to god we are we are turning this car around and doing
the side quest chat we don't then why are you complaining
you guys don't even know which one were the side quests all
right go to the quest menu you guys didn't even know oh okay
guys this is awkward because they still have not yet fixed
this that's the guy that planted it how do i how do i
improve my home that i'm gonna leave anyway like guy guy
that planted this you said you said there were side quests i
should be doing where is it thinking thank you got the email
that received a gift and membership thanks oh hi dokey this
guy's only here for the chat that dargoons were the main
show for gabila and dokey was the bonus um suspicious yeah
but which one is the one that would unlock stuff guys you
can't just be like go look at the yellows not every yellow
is a fucking side quest i should be doing
And it's fine.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
Uh, have you forgotten?
Dragoons argue with each other as much as we complain.
Thank you.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Guys, like not every side quest here indicates the one that
will give me the, that will give me free shit.
Okay.
Cause I'm done.
Thank you, the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
improve your home with putting green.
Yeah, I guess it could be the suspicious cave.
Okay, I'm gonna go check out the suspicious cave.
That has to be it.
I swear to God, if this doesn't give me what I want, I swear
to God, chat.
Ooh.
You don't want to make Doki angry.
I'm practicing.
Let me put my white shirt on.
Okay.
all right all right hey um let's see i'm gonna head this way
uh this this is one of them all right let's hope this is one
of them we don't want to see we should think about stopping
by that campsite they're using ourselves uh burrito thank
you this is richard thank you thank you you think about it
life is just a serious aside quest let us live our life toky
thank you for the super chat thank you thank you all right
let's see ten dollars for chat we deserve ginger thank you
thank you who the fuck are you zeff who are you are we just
created for just this quest going my way what's up old man
Thank you for the 10 gifted shit.
Thank you, thank you.
Wait, I should learn to read your name.
Sorry, I can't read very well.
Especially, like, I can't read English very well.
So, like, any other language is also pretty bad for me.
So, let me actually learn to read your name because you've
been supporting me a lot.
All right.
Parupo.
I hope I pronounced it right.
Parupo, thank you for the...
Thank you for the 10 gifted shit.
Thank you.
Yep.
I'm the fiend prince of Yelzebub.
That is me!
Yep!
Wait, I can actually do his voice.
I'm the crown prince of Biazabub!
Am I close?
Did he just click his tongue at the prince?
He must not know the meaning of fear.
Hey!
No?
Guys, you're supposed to be my fucking echo chamber.
So what if you're the fiend prince?
I'm a hunter.
What's the point of streaming?
If I have not created an echo chamber, to say I'm right on
everything.
And a Gegee Dragon is the next target I plan on bagging.
A demon child's nothing in comparison.
You're hunting Gegee Dragons?
What's Gegee Dragons?
Are those the ones I've been running over?
Best drop that dud of a plan now.
Even I'm no match for that beast.
Ha!
Don't put you and me in the same basket.
I've compiled the Gegee Dragon strategy guide to bring it
down.
Sounds interesting.
Let me take a look at it.
Oh Way to kill the Gedgy dragon if one really exists.
I'm also interested.
Oh That's the thing that chased me in the back.
Let's make the mystique.
Let's go Environment is what was it environment terrorism
you'll have to fetch it you can logical terrorism Is that
what's called like making a fucking species extinct bring it
to me and I'll let you read it heck I guess In game In game
In game guys Wait what is that What's eco terrorism then Is
that really bad?
I mean it's Wait actually they're all really bad Oh shit
Sorry I didn't know what it actually means Wait let me look
it up Oh my god Wait what did I just say Yay to you because
okay I thought that meant getting rid of oh that's when you
support the environment and you do bad thing oh sorry I'm
here to do the opposite of that but like but to make things
extinct oh okay yeah we're not doing that it's the opposite
of that okay I learned something new today guys okay guys
thank you for educating me all right guys thank you for
educating me guys I got educated so yay see this is a
learning stream guys we're all learning together about what
words mean chat we're all concerning all right I hope Bandai
is not watching me right now I'm sorry
I know Bandai's not watching because like they're they're
legally obligated to be like hi Doki if they're in my chat
yeah Bandai Bandai all right uh uh let's see where where did
I this quote oh wait no i wait i was supposed to still be
there the cave is here all right all right how do i get into
this suspicious cave
oh there it is that the case it has to be it oh nope okay
get off this though probably not by hand i need to change it
to this yeah get off your truck old man Oh, okay Wait, wait
Plot guy Oh shit, okay, wait Zia, thank you for the super
chat Since Doki wants to be told Exactly, that's right,
that's me Desert Desert soldier recruits Moss who will then
give you the Mysterious voice side quest In town Who the
fuck is a desert soldier?
Oh, is this it?
Wait, wait, wait Wait, oh, there it is!
Okay, well, there's still gonna be a dragon problem.
Here, guys.
Oh, well.
Oh, my God.
We don't care about that.
Sorry, sorry, man.
Your side quest was not as important.
This way.
All right, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Yeah, I'm thinking about the super chat.
Doki wants to be the captain planet villain.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You think about it.
The kids on Cat's and Planet, they're the bad guys.
They win it.
They do extreme things.
What to do?
I'm in a bind, yes.
Oh.
Hello?
I hear mumbling.
Desert Soldier.
Yes, I'm busted.
This must be my end, yes.
What?
Why?
Oh, Sharko, thank you for the super chat.
No, no, I am not.
I'm not.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
What are you going on about?
Wait, you're not a wannabe junker?
Of course not.
Yeah.
I'm the fiend prince.
I'm the fiend prince Biazzabub.
You're fiend!
Shaking in your boots, are you?
You're scary, yes.
Also, are you seeing Captain Planet?
I'll take up the many one right now.
Even a fiend.
You can tell, like, people who don't know what you're
talking, like, the age differences between the people my
chat with the people who don't know who the captain planet
is and the people who do so like it like sort of dates you
dates you the only reason i know who captain planet is is
because of rick and morty so like that sort of like tells
like i was not there to watch captain planet
he's no turkey oh no she's profiling us okay guys when the
cattling planet release captain planet um release year 1990
oh my god have they I'm pretty sure they've never made a
sequel um I've never heard anything.
Oh, wait.
The new adventures of Captain Planet.
When was this?
Oh, no.
That was also pretty old.
Don't you stop.
Oh, shit.
1990?
Oh, I knew it was old, but I realized it was that old.
Oh.
all right all right let's see it's okay guys it's okay guys
don't that's why i'm streaming this early so it's not past
your bedtime
thank you super chat thank you hey chat you're all looking
good today how you've been playing any good games doing
anything fun this summer stay cool chat thank you Superchat,
thank you, thank you.
Yeah.
Cosic, thank you, the Superchat, thank you, thank you.
Okay, grandma.
Thank you so much!
Hmm.
Where to start?
Well, as you can see, I'm hiding from wannabe junkers.
All because I've earned their ire.
You pissed them off enough to need to go on the run from
them?
The Junkers?
What did you do?
Yes.
It's just the way I am, yes.
Whenever someone forbids me from doing something, I feel
compelled to do something.
Gringo, thank you.
Which is exactly what got me on their bad side.
What'd you do?
Yeah, what did you do?
When I was in the Royal Army, while on patrol with my unit,
we came across a caravan being attacked by wannabe Junkers,
yes?
our captain was apparently friends with some of those
wannabe junkers he forbade us to rescue the caravan yes the
second I heard that I knew I just had to go save the caravan
oh my god he's a good guy I plowed on in with my tank and
drove them away yes oh okay I thought he meant he ran them
over with his tank and I was Like, maybe he's not that good
of a guy.
Hey!
I would want to be junkers on my tail.
I was like, whoa.
I don't know if a good guy would run people over with their
cat tank.
Now I'm hiding away in here, yes.
But it won't be long before they find this old shack.
And when they do, I just know I'll be...
What will you be?
I shuddered even think of it.
forbidden, huh?
Thank you, thank you for the super chatting.
Thank you.
If I like being old, I have old man power.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You get to have your own credit card and your own mortgage.
You know, it's good to be old because that means you can
have credit cards.
And by having credit cards, you can super chat to your
Yoshi.
Yeah?
Hey, hear that?
True.
Wink, wink.
I'm feeling hot.
Thank you for the 10 gift.
Thank you.
It's your fault, Prince.
It's my fault.
It's never my fault.
All right.
I'm bold to assume I have good credit.
Ooh, the woes of being...
What the fuck?
Where did these guys come from?
Oh, okay.
These are the guys that...
These okay guys, I'm gonna do something not very All right,
you pissed me off guys I was just wanted to color my tank
There we go.
This might be a little extreme Now it's my turn to run them
over true boomers unite They smile.
Thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you.
Gary.
Thank you for the super chat Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Yeah That means I can Yes, you're free now A bit of an
overkill bringing in the tank But that's okay What do you
mean?
Do whatever you want Yeah, you're free now Sure, but now
that I've been discharged from the royal army I don't have
anywhere to go Come live in my town For real If he's got
nowhere else to go I am a just How about inviting him to
Spino?
was also the devil right you can just go to spino yeah thank
you thank you wink wink it's a town looking for new
residents marvelous yeah you're literally our first resident
after eight hours we finally recruited another civilian well
there's so few inhabitants it's almost a ghost town oh but
it's not my fault though i think they'd be happy to have you
I'm living in my empty ass town so I can tax you later.
In that case, I might indeed be of use to them, yes.
I'll give it a shot, yes.
Oh my god, thank you!
Can I now color my tank?
Is my tank, like, colorable now?
Okay, let's check.
Oh my god, this is what it's like to have, like, a new
resident.
I'll try my best to be useful to everyone, yes.
Now pay my taxes.
all right and then he's supposed to give me a quest too
where is he where do you live where the fuck do you live
okay what did the what did the dragon who plotted to say i
after after i saved that man's life because now he owes me
in the back do i just like talk to him okay let's see
already?
I just recruited him.
Yeah, of course.
If you live in my town, you would get good taxes, not the
fake taxes, and wherever you live now.
Uh.
Where is he?
Why is he hiding from me?
I don't understand.
Why would you hide from me?
why where are you i need the taxes
the other side where the fuck is he wait is he actually
hiding from is he there you are hello oh shit no yes oh wait
what is that it The taxa mat.
Oh my god.
Guy, who planted this?
What quest do I have to do next?
Cool quest.
Yeah, cool quest, bro.
Born to be silly.
Obligated to tax evade.
Alright.
I guess I have to go out?
Oh, go outside and reload.
Oh, okay.
Sorry.
My man has to...
be my man has to reload his brain real quick no it still
isn't offering it to me oh my god are you fucking kidding me
you're still not gonna offer me the quest are you serious
i'm coming over the tax man is coming are you ready to pay
the tax toll the warrior the money okay yes what the you
you're living in my town for free give me my quest every new
civilian that moves into this quest has to has to pay the
tax or give me a quest the tax man is scary listen my man
needs to be in the mood for questing okay oh i need to
finish the cave are you fucking kidding me no i have to make
things?
Ah, fine.
I guess if I am going to kill off an entire race, I guess I
I'm the best person for the job.
Alright.
Where is my motorcycle?
It's a very short quest.
I mean, I know, because I'm very good at it.
Alright, here you go.
I'm very good at at killing things in game.
all right it is right here all right this is it
yeah we're coming over every the things I do so I can put
stickers on my car you never know when something you've
picked up my come here oh is that the strategy guide wait
what the fuck where is he Oh my god, this is just free shit.
Is that it?
Give the guy to...
Wait, there's no dragon here!
I've been lied to!
It's literally just free items!
Alright.
There you go.
Is that it?
Is that everything?
I think that's everything.
Alright, let's go back up.
It looks like we're not the only travelers out here.
all right i got you the book stopping by that campsite
they're using ourselves where are you camp that's open to
all travelers wait where's the guy where is he oh he's over
here all right i got you your my dude oh you really brought
it thanks here's your reward still talk about tough luck
after so many natural disasters Set there might be other
blocked caves like this one true.
We'll keep an eye out for them Mm-hmm.
Never mind that you'll let me read that guide right?
Yeah Seth the giant beast hunter wrote it read it with care.
Oh He gave the instruction guide on how to kill other beasts
I have here What sloppy handwriting a good match for Kyuki
This looks like it was written by a toddler I wrote it on
the road So you might have to squint a little What the fuck
just rewrite it?
But it can't be that bad You write and drive?
Guys, don't write and drive Oh my god, Ziff!
Like right here, it says Why are you teaching these kids to
write and drive?
See?
Damn, I guess I have to rewrite it.
How unlucky can you get?
next time sit down yeah this is why guys don't write and
drive everybody i know that i'll rewrite it carefully once i
find a base for my hunt a base you're looking for a place to
wait live in my house you should go to spino then yeah spino
oh my god finally another resident attacks i see which means
there aren't a whole lot of inhabitants yet oh my god guys
Our town is going to be so rich.
And by so rich, the one person that runs the town is going
to be so rich.
All right.
I'll move into that.
And once I'm done with the book, Gaggie Dragon will be on
the menu.
I guess you'll be going hungry.
Another civilian.
I think you're unfortunately right.
Double the people.
Double the taxes.
That's economics, baby.
All right, now, now I should have some quests now, right?
Oh, wait, I gotta get rid of all these checkmarks I made.
All right, here we go.
A true gamer grinding for hours just for cosmetics.
Nice, sir.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Looks like you'll have to put up with me for a while.
Infinite money glitch!
Not for the citizens living here, of course, but for me!
oh is that it do i now have enough civilians for a quest oh
my god hello sir i got us i got us some civilians mayor as i
thought we don't have enough enough what yeah what's going
on grandpa oh it's you beelzebub well spino has been really
picking up lately isn't that good news Yeah, which is why I
thought this would be a great opportunity or what to build
new facilities.
Oh my god That sounds great.
Where's the problem?
We can finally have new homes We don't have enough materials
to build new bridges or buildings.
Oh Okay, yeah, we're poor we can make do salvaging old I
forgot about that But scraps are scraps.
I'd like to use something more to I don't know much about
construction yeah it does work is hard go faster if I could
lay hands on some raptor steel that fucking damn it not the
raptor seal what's that it's a kind of metal that's been
alloyed with raptor scales it's stronger and more malleable
than normal steel bolts nuts you can even make pipes with it
it can be used for almost anything.
It can be used to upgrade vehicles, too.
I know that.
I've been using it for vehicles.
Upgrade vehicles?
For real?
Beasabub.
We've been doing this for, like, the last two parts.
I'll help you get some if it means we can upgrade our stuff.
I love the 3D models for this game.
It's so good.
I think it's the fact... It doesn't look like a 3D model,
too.
Wonderful.
Your help would be most appreciated.
However...
watcher thank you for chatting thank you more pilots only a
skilled material processor would be capable of crafting some
now we just need to bring someone like that to spino a
skilled material processor oh that's right back in the day i
used to know a skilled craftsman called nors nowadays he's
running a workshop in talbot i think could you go see him
for me Of course.
Okay.
Guys, I just realized I put so much effort.
Like, I'm putting so much effort in this town.
But we're going to be leaving this town the moment I get the
stickers and everything I've done to this town will be for
nothing.
Because I won't be able to use it.
I won't even be able to use this stupid village.
Don't think about it yeah for the stickers don't keep just
think about the sticker yes just i just want to paint i just
want to paint the tank and use my 50 chairs that's all i
want Where does this guy fucking live?
Where does he live?
Get the flowers.
Is it this one?
That's me this one, right?
Icon list.
Okay, I need to get rid of some stuff on my icon list.
I feel like you are...
Okay, I need to know where I am.
Um...
What is this?
Where's self?
Self?
Okay, north is up.
Self is down.
Right?
Crying.
Where is it?
Grado.
Tabo.
What's this?
Where is it?
You guys lied to me.
Where the fuck is it?
Where's Tabo?
Guys, where is Tabo?
Okay.
This is the NAPS base.
This is NAPS checkpoint.
Oh, there's Tabo!
Oh, there it is.
I found Tabo.
Oh my god.
in here i'm gonna abduct you to my town stat wait his name
is stan we're in an area where people's names are fucking
bezel bub and your name is stan uh all right and what does a
demon like you want with me huh we need you for parts for a
material processor called norse stand the man
You're not gonna find him Don't bully the man Cast that dude
Yeah cast is it because your name is also Stan He's just in
Oh shit I'm sorry Stan Bro oh my god that is sad Guys You
made him you made Stan sad For real How are we supposed to
get Raptor steel now Yeah I was supposed to get that stuff.
Who mean I'm the rude one?
No worries there.
Pop taught me the trade.
Get me any order?
Or live in my town, son?
Then come work as a material processor in Spino.
Yeah, live in my town.
Wait, how'd we even get on this subject?
Why would you want to live here?
Didn't you want Raptor steel?
Yeah, but we want it to be convenient.
Uh-huh.
But you see, There's this town.
I like how we don't even...
We skipped the explanation.
So Spino needs a material processor.
And the mayor remembered my pop.
Sorry to say this after you came all this way.
What?
But no can do.
But our town doesn't have a stand.
We need to fill the quota of names.
I can't just leave my little sister here on her own.
She can live with us.
Is her name...
Is her name also Stan?
Damn it.
Why can't her little sister live with us?
Oh, her name is Vess.
I heard everything.
Don't worry, little demon.
I'll come to Spino.
Stand it.
Yeah.
Vess.
Don't talk nonsense.
It's not nonsense.
I've been thinking for a while.
You didn't even know Spino existed.
That I want to leave the nest and open it.
Okay, I was gonna say she's like, the moment I heard Spino
like five minutes ago, I knew that was the town for me.
No, I won't allow it.
Even with Pop's friend there, you can't go to a new town
alone.
It's always the same with you.
We got the woman.
It's so sad.
Let me live my own life.
Yeah.
I said no.
period if you won't listen then i'll go to spino myself what
the okay that's like fucked up bro this is like her dream
and then you're like you know what fuck you i'm gonna take
your dream i bet they'd rather have someone skilled oh what
you say don't think i didn't hear that wow stan rude wait
you're right we need women in this town we recruit two
civilians guys we need to balance the population down in our
town of course I am that's it let's face off to see who will
go to oh shit fight fight fight face off we'll both make
raptor steal and see whose is better this little demon here
will be the judge winner goes to Spino sounds fun oh my god
I get free raptor I love free stuff that okay with you
little demon fine by me No, no, this is just like my
Japanese fan comment
Right after you lend us a pure raptor scale that is oh now
you guys don't want Stan Just because we have best now what
happened guys you guys were cheering on Stan, but now you
don't want him anymore Not loyal.
That's what happened.
We just ran out.
Ah, sure.
Alright.
We need some peruptar scales.
Do I have peruptar scales?
You need pureaptor scales to make raptor steel.
There's a raptor cave north.
Wait, did I run out?
How did I fucking run out?
Okay, where the fuck is the cave?
This one.
Right?
Paterno.
All right.
We'll just.
There has to be some raptors nearby.
You have to give.
Yeah, but like.
But like how.
When did I run out of fucking scales?
Can I just buy them?
Pedler.
Uh.
Thank you for coming.
You're not useful at all.
All right.
North or something.
This is North.
Oh, there it is.
All right.
Oh, I should get rid of this, then.
All right, there you go.
Oh, I should get a tank.
Because we're going to be running over some raptors.
All right.
He just told me, yes, but he used cardinal directions.
Guys, I don't think you remember.
You guys forgot I'm stupid.
All right, nice.
We're going to kill the whole family because this is
important.
Oh, hey, nice.
Three for one special.
Oh, we've been!
There was someone there to rescue?
That is.
Wait, that's just a raptor skill.
Wait, it's just a regular raptor skill.
Any special raptor skill?
Magister, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Since we're all boomers here, can you finish this sentence?
And that's the bottom line because...
Is that a reference to something?
thank you the super chat thank you thank you behind me back
when Talbo was thriving this town was filled to the brim
with craftsmen alright guys leave me alone are the only ones
left I don't get that rep guys don't pretend you don't
understand that reference guys don't
Guys, don't pretend, guys.
Oh, there it is.
There's the Raptor Cave.
Raptor Cave must be close.
What do you mean, we're literally here?
Oh.
Your Raptors are rare.
I doubt they'll be that easy to find.
What is a Preraptor?
I thought all Raptors are the same.
My God, look, there's eggs.
You make me feel...
Oh!
That's why you watch me to feel young again guys I'm here to
make you guys feel young again Yeah, peraptor the raptor
No, oh my tank yes, no my tank can't fucking go upstairs
This is fucked up This is so fucked up Here Where is it
where is the peraptor oh there he is is uh oh my god they're
white okay guys you know they said they're very rare so
let's make them rip so let's make them rare
give me a sec
I need these material.
Supply and demand, baby.
Alright, nice.
We did it.
Rare to endanger.
Yay!
Make-to-make's doing for the- Guys, it's for the stickers!
Guys.
Toki, yes!
It's for the stickers!
We worked so hard.
for those stickers chat all right let's see uh where is
there you go talbo if you ever think you might be lost you
should check the map that's on them for not for not adapting
to the tanks oh oh i either guys i think like i give the
raptor steel to either stand or vest to choose whoever we
want, guys.
All right, who are the standstands?
Is that true?
Whoever I give the pro-raptor steal to will be coming to my
town.
Just want to be sure.
Doki needs stickers more than the world need raptors.
It's for a good cause.
Cass, thank you for the stupid chat.
Thank you.
Come on.
Is that true?
Like, whoever I talked to would come to my town?
Let Vez be independent.
Yeah, but why would I have to talk to both of them?
Oh, oh, they both make it.
You just choose in the end?
Okay, guys, they both make it, but I'll make the poll now in
advance.
We must fix the gender imbalance.
Stan, the man versus Vez, the woman.
I don't know.
I don't know what else to call it.
Okay.
Alright.
Alright, guys.
Here's your pull.
Best.
The last.
Okay.
Here.
Will this Pyraptor scale work?
Oh, geez.
You actually got me one.
What?
Yeah, what I feel bad but I was hoping you wouldn't find any
so we could call this thing off And forget about any of us
going to another town So that was your plan how dare you
since you brought one I've got to do my job I worked so hard
killing off a species to make them endangered.
I'll make my best raptor steel yet No, no, yeah.
There.
Done.
This is why Vest is winning.
The raptor steel Norris taught me to make.
One look at that tells me how skilled a craftsman your
father must have been.
And it seems the apple hasn't fallen far from the tree.
It's always nice to hear Pop get compliments.
I'm pretty sure I'll win this.
But it's all in your hands now.
All right, let's see what Vest will say.
All right.
All right, let's see what Vest says.
Hey, Vest will appreciate me more.
Yes, that's it.
Talk to people in the super chat.
Thank you.
Who would win a million years of evolution or one tank?
Thank you in the super chat.
Thank you.
Hey, are you sure?
Oh, hey, Vest doesn't know how to make this, guys.
Like, Guys, it's her first time making Raptor Steel.
You still want Vess?
Oh, but don't worry, okay?
If my tank falls apart because we got Vess and she does not
know quality control, I swear to God.
I watched Stan make it before.
How are we supposed to not worry?
Anyway, I'll get right to it.
Good luck.
Here, check it out.
I did good, right?
Guys, guys.
You have to admit, it doesn't look like it's your first
time.
Oh, shit, Ralph!
That's so out of context.
Maybe to the untrained eye.
Give that here.
Look closely.
Scratch it a little with a tool.
And...
Wait, what, and what and what?
The plating came right off.
Guys, the plating came right off, guys.
Guys, my tank falls apart.
No way.
Why?
I bet you forgot to treat the base metal surface.
This.
Let's give her a chance, Toki.
Skip that step and the plating will come right off.
She literally skipped the step, guys!
It just slipped my mind is off.
Oh, uh-huh.
Please, give me another chance.
Sure, why not?
Okay, she sucks, but hear me out.
I should thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Go ahead.
Do it as many times as you need.
She needs training.
Who's going to train her?
We're picking one person.
Thanks.
I'll need more skills then.
She needs me to kill up more raptors so she can get better.
Right.
Well, guess we have to get more.
I have to get more?
Guys, I have to get more skills because of her.
Here you go.
This is training.
Don't you.
I'll get started right away.
Oh, thank God I had enough.
Not God.
Okay, what about this girl cute?
Scrooge, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, Stan's gonna be like, I'm actually her.
Don't you think about the population?
Hey, demon buddy.
You confident in your strength?
Of course I am.
Who do you take me for?
Then can you try bending this steel with all your strength?
No matter how strong he is, it's impossible.
I'm the fiend Prince Beelzebub.
Don't doubt my strength.
Did I bend it?
I did it!
I cracked it!
No way!
Guys!
How's that possible?
If we fucking used her Raptor Steel to upgrade my tank, my
tank is gonna get bent in half!
What temperature did you do to heat treatment at?
About 520 degrees Fahrenheit, I think.
But she's learning to...
It doesn't count.
He's literally Goku too.
What's with you?
Stop bullying me already.
If I was Goku too, I would not be using a tank to kill
everything.
What he's doing?
To me, it looks like he's trying to guide you.
Oh, I get it now.
Stan's just trying to teach her.
Little fiend.
Give me one last chance.
If I had Stan, I wouldn't have to teach.
teach her anything, because I could just leave her in this
village.
I'll succeed for sure this time.
I promise.
You've helped her this far.
Why not stick with it to the end?
That's true.
I already killed off the population in that cave.
I might as well.
Oh, thank you.
You're the best.
Just have them marry.
They're fucking brother and sister.
Muse.
Do you want to change your answer?
Musa?
It's hard to make you go out again.
But this is the last time.
If it's another flop, I'll give up on going to Spino.
It's done.
This is the apocalypse not nitpicking.
We just discovered water!
It's not even the apocalypse.
It's the one guy that was like, I'm gonna tax the water.
Like, we literally discovered water.
It's not even Apocalypse anymore
It's pretty much Oh my god Wait she is a prodigy What the
fuck Wait Dragoons This guy took years to learn this
Actually It might even be better Wait a minute Guys wait Was
she actually a prodigy Guys I told you guys I knew we had to
just We had to just nurture her until she became even better
than her brother.
I fucking called it.
I always believed in you, Vess.
She was just an unpolished rock, Crystal.
I mean, my raptor steel is ready.
I knew it.
I fucking knew it.
We have to give another one to Vess.
No, I just...
All right, Stan, what do you want?
Both our Raptor steals are ready.
Win or lose, no grudges.
Please speak to the person you want in Spino.
Oh, okay.
Got it.
All right.
All right, guys.
I don't know.
He literally said that it's better than him.
Guys, I knew it.
She was just an unpolished diamond, guys.
She was an unpolished diamond.
polished her so now so now she's gonna she's gonna be the
one i knew it you sure you want me of course vests of course
it was always you vests you're younger than stan and like um
uh yeah diamond you're younger than stan but like your first
try only it only took four actually your fourth try It
literally only took four tries to be better than him.
So of course, Vess.
Of course I want you in my town.
I beat Stan.
You did it, girl.
You beat him.
You were always my first choice, Vess.
You were always my first choice.
I needed a second chance and a second second chance.
But you chose me.
So I'll do my best not to disobey.
point you maister thank you the super chat thank you thank
you uh not fair stan is under the weather because his
favorite rapper didn't respond to his letters thank you with
a super chat thank you no name thank you super chat thank
you thank you nah stan just sucks he didn't notice since
there's not many blacks in minutes thank you for the super
chat thank you thank you and unreliable oh shit wait what do
you mean unreliable sad you did not let me read the fine
print Sen!
What do you mean, unreliable?
Sen!
Guys, can I get a refund?
I can fix it.
I'm sure she'll surpass me someday.
It's your problem now.
Guys, what the fuck?
What the fuck does he mean, unreliable?
Sen!
Right before she passed.
Mom asked, I hope I was able to fulfill her dying wish.
Now she is your problem.
Dang it.
Now's not the time to be getting all gloomy.
Guys.
It's our last night.
I've got to be cheerful for her sake.
Guys, I don't know what he meant by that.
He didn't explain anything to me.
Now I'm a little worried.
Yeah, I'm a craftsman now.
you made the choice turkey now live with it cause i think it
was super chat thank you thank you you're gonna be seeing a
lot more of me from now on well the moment i finally able to
decorate my tank like i'm gone i'm fucking gone from this
town we're never coming back here tour back here again i see
zeph wants to talk to you something about furniture ah yes
apologies When looking out from this spot, I can feel the
town's vitality.
I suppose that's why I seem to find myself here all the
time.
I think I understand.
Though we've still a ways to go, being able to watch the
town change before our eyes.
Yeah, sorry that I didn't do this until now, guys.
Sorry to my town.
Sorry, Mayor.
I could have done this a lot.
time ago.
I don't know about that.
Bro, what the fuck?
That's an adult voice coming out of this child.
This kid fucking hit puberty.
What the hell?
I don't think any of the people I talked to ended up moving
here.
That is not a child.
If anyone deserves credit, it's you, Prince.
There's no right for time than now.
Shorty toky.
Nah, it's fine.
Not like I did it for them anyways.
I'm just in it for making our bots stronger.
In that case, we're going to need an EX chip store if we
don't want their power plateauing.
Materials and Anne's knowledge alone will only get us so
far.
Yeah, guess so.
Well, back to work.
I can't believe it.
Finally, this town has three women.
Or two, because we're taking one of them away.
Okay, direct to Greenland.
Furniture!
More specifically.
Oh my god!
My 50 chairs!
It's time!
Now that you mention it, other townsfolk had similar
grievances.
The more people come, the more necessities arise, I suppose.
It's time!
Such is the way of things.
There's no sure sign that vitality has returned to speak.
50 chairs are useful now is the time for action spino shall
shine once more looks like your vitality's return too mayor
isn't that great hugh yep oh my god it's time a new workshop
has opened at workshop you can process oras materials
collected from hunting into necessary items for modding your
vehicles a hard time finding a certain item how do i
decorate oh my god guys there's actual bridges now holy shit
the town is actually different another failure what best
don't make me regret this decision hey best what are you up
to you got eyes right yeah but that doesn't mean i know what
i'm looking at i'm working on material processing to grow
our lineup but yeah god damn we just walked in what do you
mean vess you just witnessed me ruining some of my most
prized materials yours didn't i give you some of the
materials i bet my brother wouldn't be struggling like oh
vess You're, I don't know about this now.
Now you're making, saying these things is sort of making me
regret the decisions right now.
It's literally day one.
Oh, well, uh, good luck with that.
It's not looking good.
Hey, I know when someone's spacing out on me.
You know, if I improve my skills and our shop's lineup
grows, you'll be able to make your vehicles stronger.
would have known these are it these things already though
wait for real sad would have known already the better the
materials the better they should perform i knew you'd like
that i have a proposal a request there's a merchant named
kuo whom i know from my talbo days could you ask him to come
to spino another one wait are you trying to get someone to
come over here to like make up for your lack of experience
like i just got stan he's a peddler won't he turn up
eventually well thing is spino's apparently not what do you
mean by that what i have you know i found two other citizens
to tax today so he only swings by when he feels
Profitably profitable.
The materials I ruined just now are pretty rare.
Kuo's the only person I know who has them.
So please.
He's been obsessed with racing lately.
He's probably near the LISOB racetrack.
There's a racetrack?
Fine.
I guess it's worth it to power up our bots.
But I don't even know what he looks like.
Oh, that won't be a problem.
What does he look like?
but he's a bit hard of hearing.
You'll know him right away from his booming voice.
I feel like he'd be like the only peddler there.
Yes, that'll work.
I'll be... Thanks!
I'll get my tools polished up and ready to go!
Can you erase him?
Well, it's fun that you guys think I'm gonna do it.
I only have one goal in mine here.
Can I put stickers now?
As if I'm...
And...
Hello.
Wait, okay, I'm not talking about you, Polak.
Do you need anything?
And...
Can I...
Can I decorate my vehicle now?
Customize?
No!
See you later.
When can I...
Oh, other side quest.
Oh my god, this guy.
The soldier.
He must be able to let me customize my stuff.
The other soldier.
come over here
man what am I gonna do I can't take on monsters then that's
why you live in my town you don't have to deal with any of
that work bullshit anymore nice shriek what do you find
scarier fiends or monsters oh well I'm used to you now
Beelzebub yes anyhow what's this about monsters sorry at the
little bit for a bit longer I have to still live in this
village you go through you can hear them growl from the
cliffs peddlers are too scared to go through there now I
hear if that rumor spreads merchants might stop coming to
town no merchants already stop coming to this sound because
we're poor, Ralph!
We're fucking poor!
So now it's my job.
Just camp the monsters out.
But just because I'm an ex-soldier doesn't mean I'm a
one-man army.
No.
What does that make me?
I'm the one-man army.
Why did you take a monster hunting job in the first place?
Well, I recently took on another job from a peddler.
He had bought up too much cargo, you see?
So the job was to keep it safe until he came back.
Which I was more than happy to do, so I accepted the job
immediately.
But when the peddler left, he joked, don't you go selling
any of that out from under me now?
And, well, that gave me ideas.
No, soldiers should not have ideas, Moss.
Moss, no, no, no.
A good soldier follows.
Oh, yeah.
Never mind.
You should definitely stop having ideas.
Moss.
You're a little stupid.
You've really got to work on that habit of yours.
Cool.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
At least she is pretty top boy.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I said I'd do anything to make it up.
Turns out anything is go drive away hordes of monsters.
Moss, how could you?
Sounds like just desserts, honestly.
sounds like a good time to me then be my guest if there
really are monsters that is and if so yeah beat them up if
you can oh my god moss please what do you mean to beat up
the monsters just give me the paint let me use my chair
that's the quest.
All right.
Time to beat up some monster.
Self-time.
This one?
Light on the hilltop.
Is that the quest?
Mysterious voice.
I've never seen this one before.
It has to be this one, right?
Okay.
Oh, all right.
Let's grab my motorcycle.
Here we go.
Mysterious Voice?
Oh, Mysterious Voice is the quest.
Okay, JK.
We don't care about you anymore.
Wait, is this a waypoint?
Oh, I can.
I can just travel.
All right.
Oh, my God.
This is it.
Okay.
what the fuck the fuck is that hey hello found those
monsters hello sounds promising who's that be getting pretty
close what he disappeared oh we have to find him oh but
there's loot here where is he we have to find him
Wait, there's something over here.
There's a green thing over here.
Oh, no, that's just more gems.
JK.
That's just more.
Use a jumpa?
Oh, because of this?
So much sand flowing in.
Where does it go from here?
Wait, I can jump this.
Okay, never mind.
History far beyond our understanding.
Maybe we'll know in a thousand years.
Alright, guys.
I was just thinking, maybe I should start saving.
I was like, I feel like maybe sorry for the for that but I
feel like I don't know how much the the side quest saves so
I'm gonna start saving now sorry guys oh are you the
mysterious voice why are you scared hey what are you doing
so high up there demons please don't come any closer
Hey, that voice.
Wait, the monsters were just you groaning?
That was you?
Somebody.
Is that how you fucking cry?
Take it easy.
You're all right now.
Nerd.
Wait, you're...
You know this guy, old man?
No, I'm sorry, but I don't recognize him.
Hey, who are you?
You wouldn't.
We met over 20 years ago.
Oh, and he was a baby.
I was scared stiff up on a high place then, too.
And you saved me.
Wait, you're not that boy, Shion, are you?
That's him.
That's right.
I was crying so much that I didn't get a chance to thank
you.
I always regretted that.
And hoped I'd get another chance.
I'm glad we got that chance.
Shion from 20 years ago?
down from there before you two start catching up.
How did he get up here, though, if he's so scared of
heights?
Seems like I got down in one piece.
Thank you.
So, what are you up to these days?
Well, I've become a painter.
Oh my god!
Let's fucking go!
You sure have grown up?
Oh!
No wonder I couldn't beg you as that kid who would start
crying at the drop of
I may not be a child anymore, but I'm still just as much of
a scaredy cat.
Xeon, thank you, the super chat, thank you, thank you.
By the way, light on the hilltop unlocks furniture!
Okay, we're doing the furniture one next.
What about you, Mr. R?
You can mash the okay button when deploying a vehicle, jump
into it instantly.
From what I can see, you're on the road with some demon
friends?
You got some beef with demons.
Yeah, you got some beef there.
Chairs?
What the fuck is wrong with him?
Prince, knock it off.
We're currently traveling using Spino as our base of
operations.
Spino?
I've never been.
Oh, you're gonna love it here.
I hope you like paying taxes too.
It's a work in progress, but it's a good town.
You know, I've been looking for a place to settle down.
Oh my god, another one.
If it's good enough for you, then I'm sure it is for me.
Guys, unfortunately, we have imbalanced the towns.
We always have the welcome mat out.
We might have a town imbalance again, guys.
Trust me.
Demons aren't as fearsome as you've heard.
Are you sure?
Well, they don't look that scary.
So, maybe?
Ah, come on, old man.
You're killing my rep here.
Then my mind's made up.
I'm moving to Spina.
I don't think he's a threat in that.
What are you trying to say?
He can get a woman?
As soon as I pick up my belongings, I'll head right there.
Some women like nerds out there.
Take care of yourself.
I don't know, but the ones in my town, but like, uh, one of
them might.
I will.
See you He's a painter Just like Leonardo DiCaprio From
Titanic Guys That guy Got women He painted one like the
French girls You can't say that Oh Rod What do you mean Rod
He would a bad painter but he's hot hey his painting skills
helped out counterpoint is decaprio there's hope for
all right we gotta go get that furniture too
we gotta get that furniture and then he look we're not
talking about the fact that he died we're talking about the
fact that like uh that he did get it oh wait you're not what
i wanted to you're not the quest i needed to do so i'm sorry
i like how like in the distance i hear him yell for help
sorry you're not that important i'm sorry what wait you can
get me off the motorcycle okay i was like running over
scorpions thinking I can like I don't have to care all right
do be careful friends it's fine we can ride past this oh oh
there you go furniture is here furniture is here lead him to
get eaten look I'm sorry he's just wasn't as important we
gotta we gotta get the furniture unlocked wait guys what We
fixed the problem!
Instantly!
Hmm?
Do you see something in the sky?
Something flashed on that hill over there.
I'd love to know what it is.
But I can't see anything from here.
I've got an idea.
How about I climb on your shoulder?
Wait, what?
Wait, are you...
a... demon?
Heh.
scared you i've never been so shocked you're the first one
oh my god am i gonna be your muse she's also an artist too i
told you guys there's hope for everybody even better you're
gonna we're gonna play matchmaker as an artist demons really
are something else this girl is a total weirdo i'm out of
here i'm afraid i can't let you what i want to draw you wait
what i'm not going anywhere till i do i don't feel
comfortable with this
i'd love to get started right away but i'm the type to do
things one at a time huh which i can't wait for her she's
weird to see what that light was could you wait for me i
should be back wait three days we need you in the town now
like we'd sit around and wait that long oh what to do what
to do it'd be faster if i had a vehicle that could jump high
anyway you can't leave until i've investigated that light
understand oh i need thing for furniture i can't draw you
until i've checked it out right and i won't let you leave
until i have so you're stuck here oh my gosh she's so
Assertive.
This really is a bit of a pickle.
I'll never understand just what goes on inside artist's
heads.
Oh, I know.
You can go check it out for me and tell me what it is.
Oh, that's a lot easier.
I have a jump bot too.
Then you'll be free to leave.
Yeah, it's a win-win for everyone.
Yay.
You just have lint floating around in the head of yours.
Whoa.
Beesalbuff.
That's so rude.
Just because she's a freak doesn't mean she's dumb.
How about you open it up and take a look for me?
You're grossing me out.
Well, it seems we have no choice but to do as she asked.
Fine.
I'll check that hill for you.
Guys, Beesalbuff.
Please think about the furniture, Beesalbuff.
I promise you'll get off my back once I do.
Think about the furniture!
And that 50 chair!
Come to think of it.
I haven't introduced myself.
I'm Lutemis, a craftsman.
How about you?
Whoa!
He's a child.
Yelzebub.
He might be like a 500 year old child.
But like he's still a child in demon years.
Yelzebub.
Oh, even your name is beautiful.
Whoa!
Get away from her.
oh my god we gotta go up here okay we have the jump bot uh
it's time boom alright lady we have a we have a painter nerd
just for you we just recruited one don't worry we're gonna
play matchmaker for her is it guess the light was getting
reflected off it did someone hide it here is it this
whatever Let's hurry up and tell Lutemus So we can be done
with this already.
Oh, okay.
That's fine.
Alright.
We found the treasure.
It had nothing.
Hey, we went to that hill.
Oh, what was it?
A treasure chest.
The light was glinting off it.
It was already looted.
Whoa!
A treasure chest?
There wasn't even anything in there.
The world sure is full of wonders.
That means treasure could be at the end of it.
top of other hills too well the only whoa no i guess i don't
know if i want her in my town anymore guys i think we might
have a problem whoa you wanted to draw me right get it over
with already visible no you don't don't what's the wait
don't incur don't enable air no this isn't something to be
rushed That's a bum, don't enable her!
Bearing being I've ever met.
I'll stay by your side and draw you.
Whoa!
Bro!
What the fuck is wrong with me?
You gotta be kidding me.
No way you're coming with us.
My vote is a no too.
Yeah, no, no, no, I'm sorry.
Guys, we can't.
Guys, we can't let her in.
Can you at least tell me where you live?
What?
Oh, stop!
Okay!
What the fuck?
Run her!
Run!
If I can't accompany you, I shall await your return.
Oh my god!
Uh, demon village, I guess.
But you can't live there.
Yeah, no, don't let her live there.
Don't let her live there.
Right!
Spino, they're looking for new residence.
No!
Spinoff!
Fuck!
I don't think legally she's allowed to
I was looking for a place to set up my real trade furniture
making No, no, no, no This town with you and it is better
than perfect.
I'll head there at once Oh my god Shit, what the fuck?
Holy shit This one's stopped.
Don't make eye contact and just keep walking.
Just keep walking, Bizzlebub.
Never.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, well, you shouldn't change your danger.
You don't meet someone that troublesome every day.
Finally, cheers.
Guys, guys, I don't know if...
Guys, I don't know if furniture was worth it in the end,
guys.
Guys, I finally cheers, but at what cause?
Thank you with a super chat.
Thank you.
Ninja, well, Doki, you got your wish.
You can use your chairs now.
Guys, we have chairs, though, guys.
Guys, we have chairs.
Nice.
This is one picturesque town.
Have a feeling I won't be bored around here.
You now have a room.
Your room is locked in the garage in Spino.
Get furniture to...
Okay, we are not coming.
We are not going to fucking...
Guys, we have a room, though!
Guys, we did it.
Oh, they got...
We're not going to go near that one.
woman because we have a room do you need anything yes
where's my room see you later wait how do i get to my room
is my room still locked when does it get unlocked oh my god
the town does look better but the chairs oh it's in the back
of the garage okay okay so like Wait, what?
Go around the back.
Oh, okay.
Oh, wait.
What's this?
Oh, there's free stuff.
I'm around it.
Where the fuck is my room?
Oh, to the back inside.
Guys, it's okay.
As long as we never, you know, go near her, we're fine.
Where the fuck?
Where's my room?
The shutter?
Where the fuck's my room?
No.
Wait.
Anne, where's my room?
Anne!
Maybe talk.
No, we're not going to talk to her.
We're not.
Guys, we're not going to talk.
to her guys what about the other guy wasn't it the painter
guy okay you might have to no okay okay all right it's all
right we'll be fine we'll be fine hey you're Beelzebub oh
this is a nice town full of inspiration I think I'll make
good furniture here you'll like my work too here try putting
this in your space in the garage oh and please spare me some
time to draw you oh my god she had the key
that's so up she had the key all along
all right let's get the paint as well oh my god this town is
looking like actually pretty it only took two hours
hey good to see you yes how the monster thing turn out i did
it piece of cake one hand tied behind your back huh that's
our biazza bub monsters at all just a human yeah just a nerd
he was stuck up a cliff making all sorts of weird noises you
can see why they freak people out so much to my surprise it
was shion an old acquaintance of mine he's moving to spino
treat him right would you understood yes this job anyway
everybody else has a job but he's just there thanks again i
should be squared away with that peddler now
You know, you're just giving me ideas.
He's definitely going to get into trouble again.
He's a one-man army toky.
Oh, the painter's here!
Wow, was right.
Spino really does seem like a lovely place.
We're finally going to have color!
Oh, God!
We can put decals!
Okay, we're gonna cut.
Oh my god, finally.
We finally did it.
I'm gonna decorate the room That'll never come back to after
I leave Sandland, but this is it finally it has all these
side quests has led to this one moment Oh my god, wait, why
why did Anne had like a Why did Anne had that thing on top
of her head So like like why does she had like a little the
little thingy pop up make part oh it's because of the parts
i see okay there you go move there we go oh my god finally
you can personalize your room by using press to open you can
place the furniture from the room oh my god
Guys!
Did you guys see the 50?
I can finally use my 50 fucking chairs!
Oh my god!
Oh, it's finally here!
I'm so happy!
It's finally here!
I finally...
Oh my guys!
finally here guys my 50 chairs okay choose to select okay um
selecting we need to do the virtual live thing we finally
did it oh my god this is everything we wanted and more I
can't believe it Holy shit, where the fuck is my chairs?
Oh my god, there it is!
There it is!
We finally did it!
Oh my god.
Oh, this is all I wanted to do.
Oh my god, finally.
Holy shit.
This is actually everything we wanted.
I can finally place my 50 chairs.
Yay Oh my god, I can put chairs here too.
Oh
Here we go very Here we go nice Okay, whoa, what the fuck
okay, and then two sofas too.
Okay, nice.
All right, and then just place only chairs
We did We did it!
We did it!
We got our chairs!
Oh my god, we finally got our chairs, guys.
All it took was 200 side quests.
All it took.
Okay, and then we'll put...
There you go.
Nice.
And then we should grab...
Wait, we could put a... Oh shit, we could put a car in here?
Oh my god, let's put better dragon.
Let's put a scam.
We'll put dragon in here too.
Fuck it.
We have space, right?
Do we have space for the dragon?
There we go.
Look at this spend short.
Look at that.
You know what?
Decor What is the decor gonna be like?
Okay, I can't believe it.
I knew it wasn't a myth, guys.
I fucking knew it.
I knew it was real.
You guys just thought I was crazy.
I knew.
I knew my chairs were real.
I fucking knew it.
I fucking No, I want to get rid of all the sofas and just
keep the chairs Let's see Edit furnitures Okay, how do I
make sure get rid of this?
Alright, we're gonna get rid of like the non We're like
Okay, we're gonna get rid of the sofas Okay Remove It should
be It should just be like the chairs The sofa is And yeah,
let's get rid of...
Let's get rid of the hideout beds, too.
And then...
We don't need beds here.
We have our chairs.
So...
Alright, we're gonna get rid of the...
We're gonna get rid of all the sofas.
Because this is just a chair home.
You know?
This is right...
No, no, see?
We're just getting rid of all the sofas.
Okay.
okay yep all right is that everything no there's still more
how is there still more how oh my god you're right sorry i
had 50 sofas i was like how do i still have more oh right 50
sofas now i remember how i still have more there you go me
and my chairs okay you this is beautiful Oh my god, it's a
beautiful customized color.
Ooh, decor color.
Okay, basic flooring.
Make it yellow.
And then we'll make the furniture colors too.
We gotta change the furniture color.
Oh my, we are not changing.
Okay, one of them.
You get to be special.
The one green chair.
I'm not changing every chair.
Guys, I'm not doing every fucking chair, but like this
chair, this chair is special.
Oh, we're getting rid of the cars, actually.
Let's get rid of the car.
Sorry, man.
I just realized it just doesn't fit.
I'm sorry.
I'm sorry, guys.
I know you love to be in this room, but like, honestly, who
put this one white chair here?
What the fuck are you doing here?
But it was worth it.
my 15 holy shit i went to get a drink what happened we have
our room guys we have our room
we did it guys our feng shui is off the roof right now
there's a chair among us oh my god after everything we
finally this is why i pre-ordered This is exactly why I
pre-ordered Sandland.
It was so worth it, guys.
Finally, the pre-order was worth it.
Alright.
Oh my god, I can finally put stickers.
Okay.
Alright.
Oh my god, look at all these colors!
Alright, what do I...
What?
Okay, yeah.
It has to be bright yellow so people will know I'm coming.
So they'll know.
Don't know I'm heading over.
Oh, okay.
And then we'll put...
Oh, we'll put it blue like the hat.
And then what's this?
Okay.
And then the legs.
Where's the legs?
What is this?
Oh, option one.
Okay, the legs.
Oh, wait.
No, never mind.
This looks ugly.
Okay.
What?
Decal.
Oh, my God.
We can change our decal.
Cal!
Guys, now they'll never, if only I could have changed it
early and put 105 so people won't know it's me.
Oh, there's art too!
There's logos!
And then there's like, oh, there's actual numbers!
Oh my god!
Okay, I won't put art on it.
Wait, can I put it anywhere?
Oh my god, okay, I'm gonna put...
Oh my god, we could be like...
We could be like, oh, there's a bee.
There's so many choices what is this fucking basketball this
looks like a basketball logo okay uh all right we're gonna
do oh i want to be i want to be a i want to be a oh my god
there's so many choices wait there's a blue bird where's the
blue bird oh you're right there is wait where is it where
does the decal go where does it go wait i have to pay for
this okay that's up not gonna lie Where's the decal?
My equipment may be hiding the decal?
Oh my god, that's fucked up.
That's actually fucked up.
No!
Oh my god.
I'll make sure everything has...
Okay, we're just gonna put it there.
No more eyes for you.
You don't get eyes anymore.
You don't get eyes.
I need this decal somewhere.
If it's the last.
Oh, shit.
No, that's not why I want it.
I need it somewhere.
If it's the last thing I do.
Okay.
There we go.
Okay, and then...
Can I just hold it?
Painting?
Yes!
I want that.
Okay.
I can't believe it.
I can't believe my decal didn't even show up anywhere.
Like, where the fuck you're...
I'm not gonna make this.
I'm not gonna make the tank naked.
I worked so hard to put this...
I worked so hard to get to this stage.
It's okay.
This is all I wanted.
There we go.
It's beautiful.
You're beautiful.
You're so beautiful.
Okay.
Is that it?
Do I just have to painting painted?
Did I do it?
I must have done it, right?
Yeah.
Everything's good.
All right.
It's beautiful.
Oh my gosh.
finally all right everything else I really don't care see
you all right all right goodbye town I worked so hard it
only took two hours guys but we can finally leave it only
took two hours but we can finally leave and go to Greenland
Oh my god.
Here we go.
Off the green land we go.
It was a journey.
But we're off the green land.
Did I go the wrong way for green land?
Fuck.
How do I get there?
Oh my god.
We're finally gonna see the greens guys.
We're five.
Oh my god.
Wait, we have to kill him.
We gotta make sure his we keep the species go endangered
Guys, it's a rare raptor.
It's the peruptor All right, we're just gonna oh my god.
Oh my god jokie tank in action We'll let this guy live.
We'll let the child live the last white.
It's like the last unicorn, but better because I'm the one
Doing the killer In game in game in game Dark thank you the
super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you This room reminds me of your dad's my old of your
old minecraft clip where you're inventory No, I was reading
super chat But I couldn't there's no web.
Are you serious?
We're sinking into the water.
This won't work.
Oh my god Maybe finding this was a mistake Giving them water
was a mistake.
I should never have given them water.
Where Imitter is so unorganized and destroyed the OCD.
Guys, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Wee.
Okay.
I hope I'm going the right way of this.
I went the wrong way.
God damn it!
I was supposed to hold hold wait no did I gosh where is the
oh I could just I should have just fast travel there giving
the people water was a mistake okay this way all right now
I'm closer yeah I'm closer now guys we have to head to
Greenland that's like art and After everything, after all
the quests we did, we have to progress the story.
All right, that peddler is going to die.
Immortal Joe was right.
Oh, no, my Nitro.
Discord Nitro, where are you?
You know they don't.
Guys, okay, so like...
In the past, in the past, Discord used to give out free
Nitro, the content creators.
So, like, I thought they still do that.
So I was like, hey, do you guys still give out free Nitro?
They're like, I'm sorry, Joki, we don't do that anymore.
It doesn't hurt to ask.
Like, they used to.
Oh, shit.
days so now I pay for my own nitro I'm just like you guys
check the map see I'm one with the people guys it was a
choice I'm with the people just like all of you I pay for my
own nitro stay with us can you speak tell us what happened I
I don't know it'll happen sorry I'm sorry I was like gone
for a long time I know like one of your soldiers might have
died because like I never came back but after you know
fixing up my town for in two hours now I'm here to actually
do this quest some thieves had stuck onto the ship to raid
the place while we were chasing them a mysterious armed
group suddenly showed up oh who that's when the shooting
started and at some point in all the chaos i got hit this on
the arm when it was all over the ship's cargo ended up in
that armed group's hands thieves in a mysterious armed group
both after the ship's cargo what did the ship cargo have oh
my god do you guys see that one guy just lying on the ground
dead Do you see that guy?
How long he's been dead for it?
Oh my gosh, I've been gone for a while.
Oh, shit.
I'm sorry, man.
Look, I'm sorry.
I had to paint my tank and get chairs.
Help me help.
I'm not with the royalists.
Calm yourself.
We're on your side.
You are.
Oh.
Oh, thank God he's alive.
Did he just faint from relief?
Oh.
my god maybe he shouldn't be a soldier what's this about
royal yeah who are the royalists hello sandland soldier oh
no i don't want to die don't be a little bitch get up sit
tight your wound isn't lethal what wound are you here to
save us that arm group that attacked you where'd yeah where
did it go they split up half-headed north the other half
south our leader gathered anyone who could fight and raised
south what in the world happened here yeah no idea in any
case let's get in touch with ari okay
that wound that's definitely there but can't show it to us
he's doing the football the soccer strap they got caught
between a band of thieves and some armed group
who could they have been yeah how could they steal from us
the thieves just got water back but the other groups are
mystery one soldier alluded to being mistaken for a royalist
the fuck is a royalist general r it's possible that term
refers to close allies of zeu in the king maybe the
attackers mistook the battleship guards for royalists which
means they had a grudge against zeu makes sense we're going
after the armed that fled to the north could you get in
touch with the unit that headed south understood i'll lead a
unit myself as well if things go well we can pincer the
group that fled north all right let's beat the out of them
sounds good i'll be in touch from me i'm here to seal thanks
for your cooperation why did we just offer to go after a
bunch of people we know are armed to the t because we have a
tank we can't let some unidentified armed group roam around
believe this here you go again dragging us into danger how
can we find them when all we know is they went north that's
good enough for me here we go all right let's go yeah don't
worry i know i can never get lost okay where's north
one way i can go in this path how can i get lost now oh hey
so when does the green start getting green see i know where
north is it's this way what other way could it be start by
observing them carefully knowing what they can do and what
their weaknesses are will help you fight if Okay, give me a
sec, guys.
Is it?
It has to be this way.
I'll try that next time.
Like, where else am I supposed to go?
Oh.
Wait, what?
Guys, I need to go back.
Guys, I might have went the wrong.
way guys i know which way is the right way i never get lost
it's okay i'm never lost guys i went the right way think
about stopping by that campsite there i just wanted to look
at the damn just want to do a little sightseed that's open
to all travelers okay there's an open door i would assume we
go through this door because we've never been there i know
we have to stay in sandland i thought we're gonna go to
greenland oh and then we follow this see these tire tracks
yeah see we just followed this it's just that easy yeah
nice look see we just follow these tracks the young giant
yellow mark there thank god they put yellow here look we're
doing it we're just following the wait what the wait who
killed these dynos and it's not me wait they actually die oh
my god wait there's death in this game like wait what maybe
they tried attacking the armed group and paid the price holy
shit they actually kill oh my god there's several dead
stynos here guys every time i try to kill they just run away
and be like oh they're just painted or oh Oh, they just got
lost.
Doki's just annoyed someone's taking her job.
The forever E.
I can't believe it.
There's so many dead dynos!
They're taking my job!
Can't argue with that.
Oh, shit.
Black moon here.
This will be my last super chat for the stream.
Oh, yeah, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you for all the help, too.
Forestland is four dungeon crawls and one mandatory vehicle
built away.
Have fun.
You mean I'm not going to head to Greenland?
The Greenland is four dungeons away.
It's a busted army tank.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
These people are not going to be taken lightly.
I can't click thank you guys.
perhaps we should reconsider chasing them down then on the
contrary we should hurry up guys no we can't no i would have
clickbaited you guys if i don't head to greenland
guys no i swear i'm not here to clickbait guys we're gonna
be in greenland rau here general are you copy Off to green
and then not that you'll be there.
Here we go.
Oh shit, you're right.
Oh shit.
No!
Don't destroy Spino!
I literally just made the city!
Oh my god, that's so fucked up.
No, I swear to God, I literally just made the town.
I swear to God.
Oh yes, it's still okay.
Oh, thank God.
I feel like I would have been so mad if they destroyed
Spino.
I worked so hard on those chairs.
We should check in with her just to make sure everything is
all right.
All right.
Bro, could think of a super chat?
Thank you, thank you.
All right.
All right, Ann.
Wait, not Ann?
Polok?
Welcome back, everyone.
Hey, guys.
It's just you?
Where's Ann?
Yeah, where's Ann?
She went off to the Lysop Junker Market.
To do some bargain hunting.
Alone?
Without us?
But she's a...
She's a gadget in our Chippendale group.
I see.
Everybody needs one gadget.
Oh.
Oh, wait, what?
What?
That's a junker from...
That's a junker from the other town.
Is he okay?
He can't be dead.
There's no dead people in this game.
Hey, are you okay?
There's apparently dead raptors.
Wait.
he walked all the way here?
Junkers Market so far.
They know how to fight.
It took all I had in me just to run away.
How did you run here?
Old man.
It could be the armed group.
The market?
But Ant of the market now.
Ant's there.
He fast traveled.
You're not the only one that can fast travel.
Travel dokey.
We've got to, right?
Yeah!
He's a gadget!
She's a gadget!
Let's hurry.
So we have to find a new gadget and that's too much work.
Or wait, Pollock's also a woman.
We can replace her.
We can replace her with Pollock.
Her new alien wife.
All right, let's go.
Let's fast travel.
We can't fast travel!
Oh my, that's so fucked up.
Oh, thank God.
I was gonna say...
I was gonna say, are you gonna actually make me fucking walk
all the way there?
I would have been so sad.
Okay, this way.
Yay!
Whoa.
yeah okay we're gonna have to head to this way right am I
going the right way yeah I just don't know if I'm going the
right way okay looks like we're not the only travelers out
here we should think about stopping by that campsite they're
using ourselves Prince is that is everybody okay is that
good fire or bad fire hey they're alive doesn't seem too bad
you guys are alive it's you guys did you come to save me
yeah looking for a young woman named anne no we're only here
for anne a woman a woman a woman yeah the bad guys were
headed toward the least on battleship and she she chased
after them she what oh my gosh she's crazy why didn't she
wait for us She could have waited for us.
Okay, we got a fine end.
Alright, off we go.
Time to find end.
I'm sad.
We can't use our bike yet.
Okay, now we can.
Alright.
Time to rescue.
And now ship cave.
Is there people in the...
Oh, shit!
I can't believe it!
A ledge?
me oh it doesn't matter anyway we had to climb doesn't
matter off we go we gotta climb anyway it's so far why
didn't we build a fast travel system in this cave all right
hope give me that mat i need that mat give me that material
oh I need to upgrade our dragoon ship.
Okay.
Oh my god, I forgot how fucking tall this mountain is.
There she is!
Wait, they wear real helmets!
Where are you from?
You better stand back, doll.
Whoa.
Oh my god, they wear real uniforms.
Compared to the ones we had to face.
Cut the crap and answer me!
Hands off you!
Damn.
Don't make me bring the tank out.
Or what?
Look at them, thief.
They're totally scared of us.
Come on, let's have some fun with this.
Hear me!
Human, I am the great Yeah, that's me Most fearsome fiend in
the world Yikes, I knew it Yeah, if I touch you, you die
They don't know anything about demons I feel like they're
supposed to look a lot scarier What the fuck?
I have a tail Is that not scary enough?
No, I'm literally pink So what if he's a demon He's still
just a kid What Take the girl and get lost if you know
what's good for you have horns Oh, can you imagine what the
brass bag home pink is so scary
I mean he could just lie instead of kill the demon Oh, shit.
Those are horns.
Sorry.
It looked like hair
Actually, it looks like hair.
I couldn't tell.
Alright.
Watch this.
Not overkill.
Boom.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
How could this block a fucking tank?
Nice.
i'm done get it now demon and his tank wait where are you
going i have to do this do what you just got here you don't
even know what's going on and what are you talking about
yeah please just let me go there's something i have to make
sure of what make sure of what she's hiding something from
us You would hide from the team, but we're family.
All right.
Oh, it has something to do with necklace.
But the three of us are coming with you.
Why would you do that?
Because you're one of us, right, Prince?
Yeah.
You're the boomer slash gadget of the group.
We always need one.
But please run if it gets dangerous, okay?
me come on let's go all right let's go dungeon number one
one of the three dungeons then where did they disappear to
last time we were here we used a different exit to escape
they probably headed in that direction
I can't believe it we don't instantly head to Greenland we
have to work for it this is bullshit oh my god do I actually
blow this fence up what the fuck are you telling me at the
jump over this oh my god that's okay no it's a fence
so the battleship crash landed in these mountains huh how
can we not jump over it hit the ground with such force that
debris was scattered all over the area that thing must be
super tough to mostly survive a landing like that here we go
I hope I get a chance to inspect it someday what the fuck
how's that fence how's that fence so difficult
Why is jumping forbidden?
This is fucked up.
I call bullshit.
I call actual bullshit.
There's no way!
Alright, we gotta find the other entrance.
How the fuck do I get to the other entrance?
Alright.
Apparently this fence is too strong for me.
And I'm lost again.
Okay, here it is.
really want to know who these people are.
Have you got some idea who they might be in?
I can't say anything.
Oh, it's here.
Can I jump over that?
What kind of answer is that?
There's no way I can jump over that.
Right?
Oh, I can.
Broko, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Like, it's like, there's no way I can jump over that.
Well, then jump bot.
Hold A for a big jump.
I didn't know.
It looked so high.
I can't believe it.
Yeah, I can fucking jump over the fence.
Like, what?
First Zayu ship.
Now the Lysob battleship.
What?
What are they after?
I cannot jump over a fence, but I can jump over that.
Something so valuable.
They'd even take on the Royal Army to get their hands on it.
It's just too high, Toki.
You don't understand.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Oh no, a chingling friends.
If only we have a large tank-like vehicle or a demon who is
trying to pick up a tank.
Let's take a look.
It's out of respect for the engineer who installed it.
Here we go.
Nice, we got that.
Oh, there's more mats.
Okay.
Grab some.
Ooh!
That's a nice engine I got.
I love free stuff.
Okay, we gotta go this way.
I'm gonna have to go up.
Wait, there's...
Oh, wait.
I thought those were dead people.
This is where we first ran into that guard bot.
Yeah.
I remember.
It's where the prince fell on his...
Here we go.
Fell in my what?
What?
Finish that sentence!
Fucking coward.
Don't have the balls to say it to my face.
Kiss this way and then to our left.
To the left, to the left.
Speed.
This door's open too.
Oh yeah, this door wasn't open before.
Weird smell.
What weird smell?
What is it, Prince?
It looks like the stairs just keep going up.
Oh, and then we're gonna have, like, a finding hole to place
the necklace in.
What the fuck?
At least that was sort of fun.
What is he doing here?
Get out of here.
Get out of here!
Get out of my 2D platform!
That's fucking right.
We're gonna do nothing!
I remember that coming up Apparently the armed group was
talking about them.
Yeah, what are the loyalists?
Sorry, I got I got a bit distracted.
It's so okay not gonna lie the holes are like very
camouflaged So like the moment you zone out for one second
and you can't see it General doesn't appear to be on this
floor whoa who's he what the fuck is this guy are you quite
sure you checked everywhere bro your neck is okay yes sir
please believe me general my guys tension hmm if that's the
case then it must be in the engine room happy i knew it epi
who what's this i think i spy some sneaky little rats oh
that's me you i'm rat bring them before me wait they have
guns though yes sir are those like night vision goggles but
it's not even night.
Damn it.
Too late to run now.
Looks like we're in a rough fight.
Don't worry.
This very, that, this very fragile bridge can handle the
tank.
Boom.
Don't worry.
Surely this tank is not going to fucking blow up.
Surely
How pathetic of you to lose to the lights and below.
It barely is.
A perfectly tank-sized catwash.
It seems that demons lack not only any semblance of
intellect, but a sense of humor as well.
That's not fair!
Mom says I'm just special.
Whoa!
Okay, this bridge should...
Alright, you know...
I don't think this bridge would fit this.
I...
Guys, I think my bridge is about to collapse.
Okay.
What material is this bridge made of?
You're right.
Now it's time to put you in your right place.
What the fuck out of your ability is this bridge?
Hey, are you alive?
Yeah, just about.
Yeah, just tank the missile.
Damn, Epi.
Risking our lives.
He's more evil than the demons.
About the demons.
what do we do oh my god throw them off the bridge if you're
evil you do it because I do it I mean I'm not evil I'm just
role playing and we get cursed with seven years of bad luck
heck no let's get back to the engine room before Epi bro
throw them off the bridge oh my god bro these soldiers are
so fucking stupid like It's literally there.
You can literally throw them off.
At least throw the humans off.
Like, they're like, oh, but what if it causes bad luck?
Then throw the people.
Like, throw the people off.
Yeah, they're superstitious about the demon.
Then what about the regular people?
Just throw them off the bridge.
Looks like they're gone.
let's follow them i don't feel comfortable leaving them
alone they said something about hey there's my brad tank
there's my tank right there never throw people off the
bridge if you're not on the fly hey do you know this half
stash guy yeah but not that well how do you know or him.
Hmm.
What was that bought of his?
I'm not sure myself.
Hmm.
Thought you'd know.
Alright.
Let's go up.
We gotta go up.
Go up the ladder.
And we have to go this way.
Whoa!
Okay, don't worry.
I got my tank.
My perfectly placed tank.
loose oh no we just gotta use this what's my hp on my tank
okay good enough and then we'll oh wait the little pew pew
pew gun it works just fine easy so fucking easy there any
more oh we have to blow this up okay and then gotta grab
some mats up top i see materials up top oh no do i need a
jump bot am i too short no wait okay we needed that anyway
it's really like an easier no i'm too short i actually have
to get a jump bot okay x while jumping in jump bot what does
that mean
um that's awkward Okay, I don't know what to do with this
information now.
Wait, what did it look like?
What did it look like, guys, to do that?
Okay, I'm going to destroy this first.
Is there, like, extra materials down here?
Why did it take me down here?
What?
What's this?
Oh, there is.
There it is.
there is extra materials i was gonna say i was like why am i
down here there is look at all the extra materials all the
extra mats oh there you go nice we got the parallel twin
engine i assume um go faster on my bike i assume okay then
jump jump oh shit oh thank god thank god there's yellow.
Guys, I love it when there's yellow on boxes so I know where
to go.
Okay, nice.
We got the fire ammo.
It's another one of those fragile containers.
How do I get up?
Oh, alright.
Upako.
Yay.
Oh, there's more containers.
Nice.
Okay, need to get off the bike.
I can't drive on the bridge.
I'm so bad at driving.
I don't really need to use it, but I'll just do it just
because.
Oh, we need to tank again.
And then we need to blow this up.
The bike is too fast.
Yeah.
It's way too fast for me.
The yellow paint is for game journalists.
Here it is.
I'm glad this game knows me well.
No name.
Thank you for this super chat.
Thank you.
That's right.
And I'm proud of it.
Guys, if it wasn't for the yellow paint, we would be here
forever, guys.
And we don't want that.
Guys, I don't know if you know this, but we don't want to be
here forever.
Wait, there's no loot here?
You'd assume they would put, like, an empty box here.
Okay.
hire me itn i'll give you the best reviews ever okay i feel
like tank is better the tank definitely causes more damage
there you go and then oh my god i just hit him and then he
fucking fell off and then goodbye is that it no there's one
more my tank literally just poked him once and he just
Ashley's so sad.
Okay, reloading.
Do I need a loot?
Loot, loot, loot, loot.
No?
Alright, we'll just ride on.
One tap.
Yeah, he got one tap so badly.
And...
Back here.
Oh, shit, that's a bomb!
Okay, nice.
Okay.
We didn't get bombed.
Okay, and then loot.
Yeah, wait for...
No, no, get away for me!
Get away for me!
Oh, okay.
Okay, we're gonna have to use a gun.
It's so difficult to shoot that.
So we need to loot that missed?
No.
Alright, we're good.
Matthew, welcome to the tomato farm.
Welcome, welcome.
Alright.
It's okay.
We're fine.
Oh, shit!
No!
Okay.
I didn't miss, guys.
It was planned.
Oh, guys.
Guys, let me see where you are.
Nice.
He's dead.
Yay, leveled up!
We did it.
Assume it's this way.
Aimed, don't go...
They're dead.
They're still dead.
So technically I aimed correctly.
Yeah, that's the crane we saw last time too.
Wait, what?
Oh, for the guard.
bot we killed last time oh we have to we have to shoot that
okay here we go okay where is it okay we gotta shoot this
there you go and then we shoot that and then we can get off
holy this is i don't know if i can call this a dungeon It's
sort of very straightforward.
Not gonna lie.
I wouldn't say this is a dungeon.
Alright.
This way.
I think it's also because, like, I've done this dungeon
before.
Get away.
Man, I'm good.
Alright.
Nice.
Yeah.
I think it's, like, I've done this part.
already before so I don't really see this as a dungeon oh my
gosh it counts wait yellow paint why does it want me to go
here oh my god there's yellow paint there's yellow paint
that means there should be loot i know there's a quest over
there but the yellow paint guys we can't just ignore the
yellow paint we gotta follow the paint guys oh shit wrong
one wait the yellow paint stopped oh no oh wait there's loot
loot guys what do you do when the yellow paint stops yeah oh
no I'm so lost without my yellow paint
It's the worst thing that could happen to me.
When there's no more yellow paint.
What do I do?
Do I go?
This way?
Is there extra loot?
Am I going the right way?
I can't tell.
Oh, I'm gonna get lost.
It has to be this way because there's so many enemies.
out of nowhere.
One down.
Yeah, it has to be this way.
So that means there has to be, like, a boss here or
something.
Oh, the yellow lights!
You're right!
We gotta follow the yellow lights!
Alright.
Oh, there's loot!
There's loot!
Wait, that's it?
I did all of that for this one box.
There's no way!
There has to be...
There has to be more.
There has to.
Oh, it's the rusty.
It's the rusty thing.
Wait, it's rusty.
I knew it.
Guys, I don't know how to get back.
But guys, think about the loot, though.
Okay.
See.
Oh, my God.
Look at all this loot.
This is everything we worked for.
Okay.
And we got a heat upgraded gun?
Alright.
We did it.
We worked so hard for this.
Wee!
Alright, off we go.
Okay, back to the main quest line now.
The loot goblin mode.
Yes, we need to upgrade our tanks!
Now back to the main quest.
If I can remember how to get there.
okay we gotta keep jumping there's someone down there yeah
that's my team because they're not they're not allowed to
ride in the same car as me so I make them walk oh this way I
have to follow the yellow lights Marsha thank you for the
super chat thank you thank you I can't call this a dungeon
it's too straightforward gets lost in me that's different
guys that's different.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Wait, is this way?
Oh shit, guys.
I, I don't know.
Guys, where did I come from?
Oh, here, here, here.
This was the yellow paint.
This was where it all started.
Where it all started, the yellow paint.
Another elevator.
You can hitch a ride up to the engine room.
Yeah.
So the engine room's directly above us.
We're almost there.
Wait, engine room's above us?
I thought engine room's in the basement.
We'd better stay on the lookout for them.
This way.
It's really like a area that we should...
No, it's this way.
Hello, guys.
Are you guys gonna watch?
Okay.
Loop.
Yay, we got desert croc oil.
Whoa!
What are you doing here?
You're not...
authorize to be here?
Get out!
Nobody likes you!
That's right.
Nobody loves you.
You're just a pure...
You're just an imitation of the real thing.
Alright.
Nice getting rid of that.
Do I need extra loot?
I'm always here for extra loot, guys.
Okay.
jump no my head i like that yeah what's his name what's his
name
if you like that guy so much what was he called
oh this seems like a yeah that seems like a tank fight
all right like i should just kill these guys with tank it's
just much faster it's just so much fast oh shit get away Is
that it?
That's all of them, right?
Just like that guy?
You like that guy name every guy?
Exactly!
I'm glad you understand.
Okay, we gotta get rid of the small of these guys.
Wait, what?
What blocked it?
Okay, where's the other one?
There he is.
Oh, come on!
Why are my missiles so tiny?
There we go.
everything.
Steve.
That's my good friend Steve.
Steve, robot man.
Alright.
Ooh.
Leave.
Then we gotta get rid of this.
And then this.
Alright.
Yay.
Steve.
Steve no Steve with the leg my good buddy Steve Steve Lego
Oh, there's more loot I mean got another engine.
Oh my god, so much loot
And whoa So many robots for me.
Why are you hiding in the corner?
Bro join the army Join the fun afraid of oh shit i'm just
gonna i'm gonna stand still just stand still and do all the
work we don't have to dodge anything oh wait is that okay
there has to be loot on this other side right i don't think
so guys no i don't waste my time i don't i don't want to
waste my time.
Wait, yellow!
The yellow light!
There has to be loot over here!
Oh my god, I fucking knew it!
Here we go!
The yellow light!
Always follow the yellow!
Is there anything here?
Oh my god, I knew it!
I knew it!
I knew there was always loot here.
thank god for yellow okay faith in the yellow and you go
back all right nice okay now i'll just ride the bike because
it's faster oh it's so hard to ride bikes inside professor
oak was right no professor oak was right You should never
ride the bike inside!
With the likes of them.
As if.
Come on, let's check out that engine room.
Are we there yet?
Are we near the engine room now?
Oh, we have to be.
There's a...
The water here.
There you go.
I should be able to drink in the tank so my tank
automatically gets healed.
From water.
I'll swap in your equipment now.
Oh, the customization.
Alright.
Where's this?
What the fuck?
Is it better?
I can't tell.
Heat upgraded.
Required.
Let's see.
Weapon.
It can break.
Shots explode.
Your vehicle is too low leveled.
Oh my god.
What?
What do you mean my vehicle is too low leveled?
What do you mean?
I can't believe it.
How dare they say that?
You're not low level.
Okay.
V8 engine.
Boost gauge use.
Plus 37.
Boost recovery.
Boost accelerator.
Built for speed.
Ooh, I like speed, though.
Maybe we should get speed.
Wait.
I don't know.
Do we get this?
V8 would be better.
Should be better.
Okay.
Reinforce Fender.
At the cost of speed.
Well, I just had speed fixed, but then I have better
defense, so I might as well.
Amagfire is an incoming.
Adds armor plates for enhanced.
I feel like defense is better.
Yeah, I'm going to get the defense.
Power plus chip.
Oh, wait.
No!
Dragoons, this is why I have better Dragoon.
Oh my god, better Dragoons.
How could you betray me like that?
After I like, uh...
After I fucking shutting you out.
A scam.
Oh my god, all my vehicles are too low level.
You're all babies!
Wait, what is he holding?
holding.
Is that the power?
How can we compete with that?
That's the... that has to be like a power core.
You've got to be kidding me.
What is it?
Yeah.
That's...
Aquanium?
Okay.
Aquamia
Oh my god, is that a queen?
Could trigger a massive explosion
The uranium of this world is just ooh talk for uranium You
mean like this What we just said it'll fucking cause a
explosion no everyone get down what oh
my god he's a whammy wait nothing happened that was
anti-climatic
yeah didn't explode don't he stop oh he's crazy he just
threw that Aquanium furnace.
I'm sorry.
This stuff will only explode at high temperatures.
Oh, it only explodes at high temperatures.
You think that's funny, you jerk?
Hand over the Aquanium.
It's not something humanity can be trusted with.
Oh, why did you guys...
You guys, I can't hear it every time.
Of course.
As if Do you take me for a fool?
Don't worry, old man.
I'll get it back by force.
Oh, shit.
All right.
It's okay.
I have to miss it.
Go ahead and try.
I'll humor you for now.
You're fucked.
You did this.
Absolutely cannot hand over the aquarium.
No!
I ruined it!
Every time he saves it down, it's just in my mind.
Guys, I ruined it.
What the fuck happened to my team?
Okay, there you go.
Can I just shoot him from up here?
Yeah.
Toki, how could you do this?
Oh, shit!
What the fuck?
Oh, okay, we're gonna...
Let me get that...
Remember that missile thing?
me fucking I can't swap okay guys I didn't realize oh no oh
no oh no we gotta get rid of the little guys though oh we
gotta get rid of the little guys oh oh that if only I had
that he jumped over it okay that's not fair he literally
jumped over it what the you can do that What a dangerous one
prince wait wait wait what was that one guys need it for
guys?
What was guys?
What was the move that that lets you let me see you summon
people?
I forgot Guys, you guys remember How do I summon people?
I don't remember
Okay I get rid of these guys There was you can you can
summon people How do I use the ally skills?
I don't remember.
Oh, God.
Okay, nice.
We got rid of him.
On the controller!
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Oh, God.
I don't remember how to summon allies.
LB.
Oh, oh, LB.
Rau, go in there.
Help.
Shoot your guy.
Oh, shit.
Yes, go, Rau.
Go.
Oh, my God.
Rau's actually helpful.
holy oh my god no no no row you're not letting you take this
kill
that robot so much yeah but he's dead that robot's dead
i did it guys what the come back the punishment for
desertion is dead Hey, come to Spino.
We're looking for new citizens.
The man's clearly a popular leader.
They're on a lunch break.
Said your prayers.
We're always looking for new citizens at Spino.
Whoa!
A quote?
Not the Aquamium.
Oh, whoa, not the Aquamium.
Why is it that everyone we fight is so good at running away?
I'll inform Ari.
We'll let the army pursue Epi.
The Equinium is our top priority now.
There might still be some left in the engine room.
Let's go check.
I think my favorite is hearing an old man call say Equinium.
God damn it, Doki, you ruined it.
that word is ruined for emmy
uh like when rouse says it too because i feel like it's even
worse when rouse says it though the one we got back from epi
must have been the only one does every battleship have one
gary thank you for the super chat thank you thank you that's
why they went for zayu ship what do you mean Zayu's personal
battleship isn't as big as the Lissab battleship, but it's
still huge.
Antigrav stones alone wouldn't be enough to fly it.
But Aquanium, that could probably do the trick.
Ah, that's why I didn't need it.
Uh-huh.
So where are you going with this?
They broke into Zayu's mobile fortress to steal the
Aquanium.
Now that we know what they're after, no!
Ah, gotcha.
If Aquanium is involved, this is a national emergency.
Wait, how much does this say this way?
Is it really that dangerous?
I don't hear it, Doki.
Why did you do this to us?
Do you know about the great explosion of 30 years ago?
I heard you mention it on the radio.
I like how it's just rousing it too.
It was a gigantic explosion which destroyed a vast area.
And the cause, or rather the fuel, to generate it was
Aquinian.
It's the simple things that make me laugh.
The great Aquinian explosion.
Sorry to pry, but it feels like there's more to the story.
You don't trust me enough to tell me?
No.
What's the real story, Raul?
Get out of my head!
There's something I haven't been able to bring myself to
tell you either.
Dark God, what's this?
Oh, no, this is your aquarium.
Thank you for the super chat.
Dark God, thank you, thank you.
My shows.
Oh, what's this?
Did you drop the aquarium and make a blurry that killed
10,000 people?
Wow.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
affiliate and thank you the super chat thank you thank you
aquarium is gonna be stuck in my head for a week you're
right let's get back all right nice is this is the arc over
are we done with what we done with the the oifies uranium
this is a serious situation dokey out there that don't the
aquarium they literally could have named it anything else
that epi guy he ran off down this side passage didn't he
could very well be a shortcut let's find out all right it's
a shortcut i like shortcuts i love shortcuts okay this is
not as short as i thought it was the You're a liar.
You said this was a shortcut.
A shortcut should be like fast travel.
The great O-Hour.
Oh,
I passed Materias?
Oh, whatever.
It's fine.
Well, I'll be.
So there was a shortcut.
That's fine.
I mean, I could go back up and get it.
Alright.
Let's go back up.
I mean, I can- I'll just bring out my bike.
I wonder if I can just like walk off.
No, I can't.
Oh, I can't walk off.
Even though it feels like there's stuff here.
This is the longest.
I missed materials?
Where?
Did I get gaslighted?
Here we go.
I fucking need gaslighted?
Where the fuck are these materials that gas- Oh, there it
is.
No, I didn't.
Oh my god, my dragon's not lying to me.
What is this?
holy shit guys he didn't lie he didn't lie at all
what uh what a legend okay nice what the heck okay i need to
get get me out of that bike get me off this bike so i can
get down not so deadpool think of a super chat thank you
thank Thank you.
Remember, Doki, even in the Apex, you'll be shooting at a
cranium.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
My mind.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
One out of ten, don't lie to throw her.
It's true.
All right.
Nice.
And then we leave.
Wait, a new general.
Who's this guy?
Elvis?
Epi blew it big time.
Pompus man?
Elvis in my anime game?
Let's get moving, guys.
The king.
Wait, why do I have two exclamation points?
Oh, are they like quests here?
Oh, they just have new stuff.
A car blueprint.
Bro, I don't need another car.
Thank you.
you all right let's head home uh back to spino we go the
king he's back you were here why didn't you come into town
the people of spino aren't exactly the biggest fans of the
royal army not that i can blame them any updates on the
current situation we ran into that armed group at the lisab
battleship what so that smoke must have been there doing
it's fine though we thumped them good yeah we that beat him
my apologies that you had to deal with them we had our hands
full subduing the detachment of enemies who went north wait
who were the people went north then army and chaos we barely
managed to fend them off they'll likely rejoin and cause
more unrest they're with zeu but who are they no idea all we
know is that they're both well organized and well armed
they're the forest land army the forest land it's green land
but that's impossible we signed an armistice with forest
land decades ago i like we have sandland and then forest
land like i but like the thing is this land isn't even
called sandland officially i'm pretty sure right like where
we're at we're it's not even officially called sandland but
yet like we have forest land so
oh is it actually officially called sand land but like sand
land was like artificially made because of one dickhead that
like decided to build a dam like that's the thing forest
like sand land was artificially made and it was so fucked up
too if you think about it I also find it hard to believe,
but they called their commander general.
That only adds up if they're part of a large, official
military.
Yes, but what makes you so certain that it's the forest land
army?
Well...
Is there going to be water land?
Don't feel you have to share it here if it involves you.
Satellite is AI generated.
I think he should know too, though.
Okay, so, like, we all know Greenland's a real country,
right?
Forestland's basically bootleg Greenland.
But, like, actually, no, Greenland is actually, like,
Iceland, and Iceland is Greenland.
Because Greenland's actually incredibly cold, but Iceland is
the actual non-Gree...
Like, Iceland is the actual, like, not-cold area.
General Ari, would you mind coming alone?
Understood.
Please, lead the way.
All right.
Follow me.
So you get click-click, baby.
Greenland and Iceland clickbaits you.
Alright, we got it.
Oh, the cat.
Najin Boo wants to talk to us.
Alright.
Hey, nice to see you again.
Is it just my imagination?
Or has the town gotten more lively?
Yeah, I did that.
Yeah, I found something cool.
Oh, thank you.
Okay, I can't afford anything.
because i have not been exploring that's okay wait why are
you so short oh my god sorry duke you're not supposed to
just ask somebody why they're so short sorry i just wasn't
expecting that he's wide
the reason i can be so sure they're from forest are you from
forest land is because i'm also originally from you are a
forest land Person?
What did you say?
You're an illegal immigrant?
Oh my god!
She's an illegal Guys, I can say it because it's just...
Holy shit!
Oh my god!
She's an illegal immigrant you can't basically it means
she's not allowed in this country
Deporter Wow
Why did you decide to come here on your own
We have aliens in the workshop But I was the only one who
made it Oh my god, there were several illegal immigrants!
And what compelled you to take the risk of coming to
Sandland?
I wanted to find people willing to help us overthrow the
forest land government.
Oh my gosh, she doesn't have a visa, guys.
What?
You're trying to stage a coup d'etat?
She's taking hard working Sandlanders jobs.
Deadpool, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, no.
They are the ones who staged the coup d'etat.
She actually took our jobs.
That land is the land of opportunity.
The ones who took over the government and imprisoned kind
King Jam out of nowhere.
Is he wearing a helmet with a horn on top?
The Forestland Army.
Oh, no, that's the Supreme General.
Imagine thank you for the super chat bro what the fuck i
feel like the helmet is like not doing it justice we've
crossed blades with that general epi you fought in the lisa
battleship before what do you think general ra bread the
leader it does line up with our intel on forest land it's
perfect don't worry you get the pass clean
so too the timing of all this makes total sense mike thank
you for the super chat thank you thank you the satellite
dream would be the perfect time for a rival nation to move
against us but surely they must realize the severe
consequences of such aggression what could possibly motivate
them to take the risk of invading us aquanium
our entire supply was lost in that explosion 30 years ago
that's not so the Lisa battleship was powered by Aquanium
and I'd bet good money that Zayu's mobile fortress was as
well we can't take our Lisa battleships Aquanium but if they
loot the fortress I'll be damned that Zayu is there no end
to the secrets he was keeping from his own army i'm going
back to the capital to request permission to mobilize the
entire army dark god thank you for the super chat thank you
thank you we had demons and we have aliens not exactly the
aliens you expect though yeah what about the queenium that's
up to you though i'd feel safer if it were in your hands
understood Someone else please say it.
Stop Mickey round saying.
Once you've collected yourselves, come speak with me.
Would your army consider joining forces with us?
I don't know.
You're an illegal immigrant.
I can't believe that's in this game.
What the fuck?
Bro, I can't believe they called her an illegal immigrant.
That's like the most out of pocket shit.
Oh, my real lie.
Hey.
Oh, my God.
That's a real written lie in this game.
What's that?
Oh, my God.
You know what?
I'm glad I did a part.
three and it was so worth it it seems to refer to those
fighting against commander bred in his army who stole
control over forest land from its king in a military coup oh
so basically all it is is a bunch of people who really hate
the guy yeah well it's a military wait but it's like a
military coup that's like the worst one isn't it like like
that's the one you don't want to happen Oh, thank you for
the super chat.
Thank you.
You're that's real bad.
I've been thinking rather than just talking.
I'm glad we went with the English.
The English stuff.
Will you come with me?
Sure.
But where?
The site of the great Aquanium explosion.
Oh.
I like how serious he just got.
He's like, oh, shit.
The Aquamium?
All right, I'll come.
Stop saying it, Ralph.
All right, I follow.
Uh, you know what?
I'm gonna call it here, guys.
I think this is the perfect time to call it today.
History
I didn't I didn't think of all the stuff we went through I
didn't think this is the perfect time To call For this part
of the stream Alright But rattle backs Don't worry part four
We'll do rattle's backstory in part four Guys I had a great
time I've been enjoying I've been enjoying this game a lot
so far Let me swap real quick Yeah Honestly, this game has
been incredibly enjoyable.
I've been like, I really like the story.
I think like the only issue I had was that dungeon, the last
dungeon, only because like if it was a new area, I would be
fine.
But the fact that like we had to redo, like not redo the
dungeon, but like, you know, like it's like a different, a
bit different, but it was still the same.
So like that was my only issue with the dungeon.
I would have been fat.
But I didn't like that.
I had to, like, redo it.
But I've been having a really...
I wish they didn't have to reuse it for the new plot area.
Anyway, let's read some super chats, everybody.
Okay, we're going to change the...
We didn't get...
We didn't get to Greenland.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
New title.
off to we got chair wait off no no we didn't get to
greenland yeah we should just do that i don't want i want
the vod washers to feel the growth of the chairs
we we didn't get to green
um ns thank you for the super chat thank you thank you this
turn events is hurting my aquarium thank you for the super
chat thank you thank you magic thank you for the super chat
Thank you.
Don't tell Isai was here.
Thank you, thank you.
Okay, like the worst part?
I think when they were like, oh my god, she's an illegal
immigrant.
Was when the... Oh, no spoilers?
Okay, okay, okay.
We'll just write off to Greenland.
Okay.
We'll just put... We don't want to spoil it.
It was when the general was like super surprised.
That was like the reaction to it was the most fucked up
part.
The fact that I was like You're a criminal
It was actually fucking crazy I was just Like shocked It
like actually I was so shocked Because like I didn't expect
that to be written out And also dumb And the fact that I was
like Like, there were several of us, but only I made it.
I'm like, oh my God.
What the fuck?
It just came out of nowhere.
It actually was just, it just happened.
Um, not so Deadpool.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Next stream time, two weeks, sandalad.
No, no, Deadpool.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
It got really real.
Like, it really...
Wait, I got real up there.
Yeah, we overthrew a government and then suddenly illegal
immigrants.
I'm like, what?
Yes, it's been a real comfy eye.
Loving the satin line playthrough.
Thank you, the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Yeah, I've been really, I've definitely been really enjoying
this.
This is, I feel like, you know, especially when a lot of us
are going in blind, like we don't know what's going to
happen.
and everything and then like like there's we've been
surprised like we there's so many moments where we're just
very surprised
so i've been having a um i've been having a great time just
like uh just like enjoying the the i guess like in like
reacting to it blind because it's not honestly been a
fucking adventure.
It's been such a fucking adventure.
Alright, let's get some.
Which one which one have we not read?
Oh my gosh.
I read a lot that's coming in, so I don't know which one I
haven't read yet.
I even think it was super chat.
Thank you.
You create an army of people willing to go to war with each
other over ice cream flavors.
Doki, you made us this way.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
Doki and Whaling Fun.
Let's go.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Not So Deadpool.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Yeah, I read a lot while coming in, so I, like, don't know
which one I haven't.
I'm trying to remember which one I haven't read yet.
Chargo, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
A bit of people here who don't even know about the Burger
King rap commercial about SpongeBob Square Ass.
Wait, is that real?
Wait, I'm one of them.
What the fuck?
How old are you, Sharko?
I'm joking.
Wait, this is 15 years ago.
What the heck?
What is this?
This is the thing that Sharko wanted us to watch.
What the fuck?
Wait, Sharko, don't tell us your age.
We don't want you to dock your age.
Like, what is this?
Oh, my God.
What is that?
When is
15 years?
There's a million views on this.
2009.
I'm surprised I actually didn't know about this.
Don't worry.
You didn't read this one yet.
I got your back, Doki.
A fire.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I'm surprised I actually didn't know about this.
Doki's got brain rot.
Johnny Lacan, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, not super chat.
Membership.
Thank you for the gift of membership.
Thank you.
It's like I know a lot of like internet shit.
So I'm really surprised I actually don't know about the
fucking Burger King, SpongeBob.
I think they phased out the Burger King man.
Because they realized that, like, he's a little freaky.
Because I don't see him anymore.
They phased out a lot of, like, the fast food mascots.
Because we don't see Rhonda McDonald anymore.
We don't see...
Okay, to be fair, the reason why we don't see Rhonda
McDonald anymore is because at one point in history, we had
a killer clown phase where, like, people were randomly
dressed up as clowns at night to just freak people.
up.
So then the McDonald's company was like, we are going to
make sure the McDonald's company slowly phased out Ronald
McDonald because of the whole like clowns dressed up like
like creepy clowns dressed up at night.
Yeah.
And then at one point it got really bad because serial
killers were starting to dress up like the clowns because
they think they could get away serial killer that dressed up
as the clown at night because they were like oh other people
are dressing up as clowns at night so they'll just think i'm
a prankster so then so then people were stopped doing it
because they're like oh my god maybe we should stop because
actual serial killers were using it so then then it just the
whole clowns at night thing just suddenly stopped happening
That was fun.
No, it was not fun because actual murderers started getting
involved, guys.
Actual murderers started getting involved.
So then it stopped.
Yeah.
And then I remember there was like that other, the Jack guy.
Was it Jack in the Box?
Oh, I love the Jack in the Box guy, though.
I missed the Jack in the Box commercial.
Cause I actually thought he was like the commercials with
that guy.
Who is he?
Okay.
Um, he was a guy that wore this giant white head with a cone
hat.
Um, I don't see Jack in the Box guy anymore.
To be fair, Jack in the Box guy is kind of hot.
Oh, it's just because he wears a suit doesn't mean he's hot.
Guys, I swear, I swear anytime some random guy wears a suit,
people would be like, but he's hot.
But then you, like, he doesn't even show the face.
It's like they'll just put a helmet on.
It's like they just put a helmet on And then you guys would
be like, oh my god, he's so hot Just because he has a suit
on The mask Stays on Okay, but here The meat of it's always
A damn suit Only if the suit Is well tailored, you don't
want Somebody to wear a suit That's like oversized Or like
two, okay, to be fair Some people will be like, no, Doki, if
it's too tight it's even better joking but if you see a guy
wearing a suit that's too big for him or a girl that's
wearing a suit too big for him it's for them it's not not
high um the slender man effect that's true people actually
thought slender men was hot i mean there was a whole shit
about like those kids that murdered because they were trying
to murder for slender men that was so fucked up Yeah, some,
yeah, it's the, there was, I don't know if people forgot
about it.
There was, like, two little girls, two little girls, like,
murdered their, like, tried to murder their friend.
Real, by the way, this is a real story.
Two little girls try to murder their friend, uh, for Slender
Men.
Because they were like, we have to do it for Slender Men to
summon him and shit like that.
And then that's why Slender Men isn't talked about anymore,
too.
gets involved people just stop talking about it because
they're like this is a this is pretty bad no it wasn't a bit
actually happened she survived yeah they it was attempted
murder they were like 12 years old yeah yeah and then like
cuz slender men was like really popular it was like super
popular and then that happened and then nobody really talks
about slender men anymore nobody talks Whoa, maybe we should
stop.
Oh my yeah, yeah, it was fucking crazy.
That was a crazy time.
And that's why Slenderman just suddenly stopped happening.
Like, like people just stopped talking about Slenderman
because, uh, because people were like, holy fuck, wait,
there's, there's real murders happening now.
Um, like the clown shit.
That's why people stop fucking dressing up as clowns at
nighttime because murderers were like, I'm going to start
dressing up as a clown too because nobody can catch me if
everybody else is dressed up as a clown.
Um, sleepy.
Thank you.
The super chat.
Usni, I refuse to accept the slander.
They sell a thirst trap calendar on the official.
Wait, what?
Jack in the box calendar.
Are you serious?
Oh my god.
Wait!
Wait, wait a minute!
Oh my god, wait, he was not joking.
2024!
Wait, I'm gonna put this on my screen.
Oh my, guys, it's like the firemanship, but for, like, fast
food!
Okay, I'm gonna put this on my screen.
You guys need to see this.
This is actually crazy.
What the fuck?
This is actually...
Wait, this is actually...
Actually real Look at this Jack's thirst trap You weren't
familiar with his game Wait, he has a ring on Is that a
wedding ring Jack?
How dare you?
Wait, is Jack in Jack in the box?
Is that in the wedding?
Is that in the wedding hat?
I don't know Jack in the box, Mary He's married?
Cricket?
Who is she?
Jack.
Jack's wife.
Cricket.
Jack.
How dare he be married?
No way.
I can't.
Oh my god.
His wife doesn't even have the head.
What the fuck?
The wife is just the regular person So that way we could all
be like the wife Wait, what the fuck?
The wife is just a regular person Oh my god I can't believe
it He has kids too I can't believe it How could Jack do this
to us?
She asked I thought it'd be like another person with the
head oh my god there was a petition to nominate him for
people's sexiest man alive wait what make jackbox people's
sexiest man alive wait what what is this wait this is from
the official tick tock oh my god bro what when guys look at
this
wait wait this is real oh my god what the fuck we're looking
at jack from jack in the bug look at this one i think i'm
holy shit okay is someone's gonna break the mode of what
society thinks is sexy why not jack let's make jackbox the
official sexiest alive oh my god i don't know if i did not
intend to go down the jack in the box rabbit hole guys i
well hello there damn jack is fucking ripped he is looking
good at bro is anybody ordering jack in the box tonight guys
who's ordering some jack in the box guys okay let me check
out oh my God, bro, he has a Funko Pop too?
Jack in the Box has a Funko Pop, and I don't...
Okay, I need to know what other pictures are on this
looking... Oh my God!
What the fuck am I... Okay, guys, you guys gotta see the
calendar.
Here's like some of the preview pictures that I saw here.
I'm gonna save this.
Um...
I need to save this for you guys.
Okay.
Look at this.
Okay, whoever took photos of this, they know what they're...
They know the target audience.
Why is he so damn ripped?
Damn.
This has to be for, like, October.
I don't know.
I forgot.
What's American Thanksgiving?
Whatever American Thanksgiving is.
That is...
There you go.
There's Jack.
Oh, my.
Look at those curly fries.
all right i think that's a good time to call it here guys i
had a great time talking to you guys and also playing
sandland today um i can't believe we spent majority of that
customizing our town but at least we finished one of the
dungeons for the uh one out of the three dungeons for
greenland hey guys uh tomorrow we have minecraft twitch
rivals on sunday um but next week is also more like I think
like one collab I moved around my collabs because we were
originally gonna have collabs next week but then like I
would relax and chill after WrestleTuber but I haven't had
chance to really relax because it was been like back to back
to back events lately so um there's literally like stage and
slam then WrestleTuber and then like a lot of collabs and
stuff in between so like um we're taking next week really
chill but tomorrow will be a Minecraft Twitch Rivals
like how far I make it in the Twitch Rivals because it's
like it's supposed to be like a 5 to 6 day event only if you
don't get eliminated.
So like each day they start they eliminate people so there's
a lot of people participating.
I think like more than a hundred content creators are
participating.
I'll put a waiting room up so you guys can see.
Oh wait no, JK it's on Twitch.
I'll give you guys the time on Twitter.
So follow me on Twitter so you guys know what time it is for
the Twitch Rivals.
Because I'll be streaming on Twitch.
Anyway, guys, as always, everybody, stay hydrated, posture
check, get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed, because you deserve
it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.